[Musique]
Kemy Seba bonsoir bonsoir à vous nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle Serview nous sommes dans
les conditions du direct est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement
kemyba 42 ans président de
l'organisation internationale urgence
panafricaniste qui lutte pour la
promotion de la justice sociale en
Afrique qui lutte contre la
malgouvernance contre la corruption de
nos élites et qui lutent contre le
néocolonialisme ces trois axes étant
tous en réalité inextricablement liés
qui organisation qui va d'ailleurs fêter
ces 10 ans l'année
prochaine accessoirement conseiller
spécial du chef de l'État du Niger
Abdrahman tiani un homme de grande
envergure qui selon moi devrait être une
source d'inspiration sur le terrain
institutionnel pour des millions de gens
en Afrique et auteur de cinq ouvrages
sur le panafricanisme et la conscience
noire homme politique béninois qui a un
projet profond précié sur le long terme
pour mon pays le Bénin et pour l'Afrique
dans sa globalité et j'ai été aussi
pendant environ 10 ans journaliste
politique chroniqueur politique et
géopolitique en Afrique
francophone on vous a reçu il y a un peu
plus de 6 ans c'était un peu peu en
caniller chicor et boxer on va avec le
poids des années essayer de mettre les
choses à plat essayer de comprendre
votre raisonnement ce qui vous anime par
où vous êtes passé par où vous passez et
par où peut-être quel chemin vous vous
destiné première question quiba on vous
reproche toujours d'être un agent de
puissance étrangère vous avez été
interpellé très récemment d'une façon
que vous allez nous décrire
pourquoi vous avez été interpellé par la
police française et ensuite pourquoi on
vous a retiré votre nationalité
française
comment alors les deux questions sont
très liées et je vous remercie déjà pour
cette invitation et il est évident qu'on
est pas obligé d'être d'accord sur tout
mais le plus important c'est ce en quoi
je crois c'est le dialogue l'interaction
l'échange il est important quand on
parle du on nous reproche de toujours
préciser le on c'est un on très élitiste
français médiatique français
qui consiste à penser que dès lors qu'on
ne travaille pas pour les intérêts de
l'oligarchie néolibérale française on
est forcément des agents d'entités
étrangèr lorsqu'on est en partenariat
avec excusez-moi ces autres entités il
se trouve que notre organisation urgence
panafricaniste a décidé depuis un
certain nombre d'années dans ce cadre de
la multipolarité et dans ce cadre aussi
de cette nécessité de pouvoir se frayer
un chemin en terme d'alliances
géostratégique et et d'organisation
géopolitique d'aller vers le sud global
d'aller à différents endroits du monde
de nouer des alliances pour avancer dans
le cadre de l'agenda qui est le NRE afin
de pouvoir lutter contre ce globalisme
néolibéral là et ça nous a emmené en
Amérique du Sud au Venezuela ça nous a
emmené en Iran ça nous a emmené en
Russie ça nous a emmené en Turquie ça
nous a emmené à Baku ça nous emmené dans
un certain nombre d'endroits sans
compter évidemment en majorité la
puisque c'est notre terre de
prédilection et c'est dans ce cadre- làà
que nous avons déployé notre stratégie
visant à faire avancer l'agenda de la
multipolarité et mettre le
panafricanisme au centre de cette
réalité c'est votre agenda ou c'est
l'agenda des autres ah c'est notre
agenda depuis toujours en 2014 dans mon
2ème ouvrage black neilis je parlais
déjà de cette nécessité de multipolarité
et j'expliquais la nécessité pour les
organisations qui s'opposaient à ce
globalisme néolibéral cette nécessité de
pouvoir s'allier à des nations qui
résistaient à cette hégémonie là à cette
unipolarité qui existe depuis
l'effondrement du mur de Berlin et qui a
vu le capitalisme passer dans sa forme
la plus dérégulée à travers le
néolibéralisme économique et sociétal
que nous connaissons il se trouve donc
que euh ce combat que nous menons depuis
un certain nombre d'années qui a connu
une un accroiss une croissance
extraordinaire en terme d'audience et un
succès d'extime réel en Afrique
francophone mais aussi dans les
territoires d'outremer euh a réussi à
soulever un certain nombre de questions
en ce qui concerne les questions liées à
l'autodétermination à la
responsabilisation de nos populations à
l'antiictimisation de nos populations
contrairement à ce qu'on veut nous faire
croire je fais toujours partie de ceux
qui pensent et qui disent qu'une
civilisation ou un peuple est détruit
par l'extérieur que s'il est rangé de
l'Intérieur donc c'est pour ça qu'on
travaille notamment contre nos élites
africaines corrompues et euh ils sont
pas tous corrompus j'ai parlé de nos
élites africaines corrompu j'ai pas
parlé de toutes les élites africaines
moiême je suis proche
d'autorité certaines autorités
africaines notamment dans saelle et le
moins qu'on Puut dire c'est qu'elles ne
sont pas corrompues elles sont dans
cette démarche
d'autodétermination dans la démarche qui
est la nôtre les autorités françaises
qui à mon sens ont des vers déformants
qui leur empêchent de voir les choses
telles qu'elles sont au lieu de se
remettre en question sur la politique
néocoloniale de la France depuis Jacques
faucard et depuis le général de Gaulle
ces autorités françaises avaient toute
la latitude de remettre en question le
logiciel la
méthodologie de de relation vis-à-vis
des autorités africaines et des pays
africains de manière générale au lieu de
ça ces autorités ont décidé de se
braquer et de considérer que tout ce qui
était fait par cette élite était des
choses bien réalisées il est important
quand même de toujours préciser une
chose quand on voit comment les
autorités
macroniennes se comportte vis-à-vis de
leur propre peuple vis-à-vis du
prolétariat français vis-à-vis des
gilets jaunes qui ont été traités comme
des sous-hommes pendant un certain
nombre de temps gilets jaunes avec
lesquels notre organisation urgence
panafricaniste a travaillé en
collaboration sur un certain nombre de
projets les gilets jaunes constitu
notamment avec lesquels on a réussi à
mener des actions contre Boloré ou des
actions de solidarité sociale entre les
peuples parce que notre discours est
sera toujours de dire que notre combat
n'est pas contre le peuple français ou
contre le prolétariat français mais
contre l'oligarchie néolibéral qui
asphixie son peuple français et qui
asphixie les populations africaines en
collaboration en concubinage insestueux
avec les oligarchies africaine et donc
les autorités françaises ont considéré
que les mobilisations à succès que nous
menons depuis certain nombre d'années et
qui selon ellees ont contribué à la
montée du sentiment antif-rançais c'est
pas le cas c'est pas le sentiment
antifrançais c'est le sentiment anti
néocolonialisme le sentiment
anti-oligarchie dégénérée néolibérale et
bien ce sentiment a permis de soulever
les question de souveraineté de
critiquer le Fran CFA sur lequel on a eu
un rôle prépondérant parce qu'on a mené
une campagne historique en 2017 et cela
a permis aussi de poser la question de
la pertinence des bases militaires
pourquoi les bases militaires françaises
présentent en Afrique alors que je me
souviens qu'à la fin de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale d'après ce que j'ai
étudié le général de Gaulle lorsque il
s'est adressé aux Américains le général
de Gaulle a dit aux Américains qu'
n'avaient pas vocation les bases
militaires américaines les militaires
américains n'avaient pas vocation à
rester sur le territoire français
pourquoi ce qui n'est pas valable pour
les Français devrait être valable pour
les Africains si décolonisation doit y
avoir ça doit être le cas partout les
autorités françaises ont considérer que
j'étais d'après ce que dit la DJS les
services secrets la figure centrale de
ce sentiment panafricaniste
hostile à la présence française en
Afrique je ne qualifierai pas ça de
cette façon je qualifierai
de leader panafricaniste qui est hostile
au processus néocolonial présent sur nos
territoire et qui veut briser cette
colonialité comme le prolétariat
français veut briser aussi ce rapport
d'oppresseur à opprimer entre les élites
corrompu dans ce pays et la population
française c'est quelque
part une marche qui est très similaire
sur un certain nombre d'aspects parce
que la colonialité recouvre un certain
nombre de de dimensions qui touchent les
populations de l'ensemble de l'humanité
en réalité avant qu'on parle de votre
interpellation comment ça s'est passé et
puis comment la suite des choses je
voudrais qu'on fasse l'avocat du diable
ensemble qu'on pense contre nous-mêmes
que vous pensiez contre
vous-même vous représentez beaucoup de
gens vous entre guillemets frayz avec
des puissances
d hostile aux intérêts
français comment ils ont pu trivialement
se monter le bourichon contre vous ils
ont des preuves ils ont fait une enquête
c'est des suputations c'est vous vous
intimider qu'est-ce que c'est pour vous
mettez-vous à la place d'un agent de
renseignement
français très bonne question je pense
que la réponse est très simple ils ont
observé depuis 2017 qu'on a réussi à
soulever des masses cons en Afrique
francophone mais aussi dans les
territoires d'outrem en Guadeloupe
Martinique mais aussi en Guyane et aussi
à la Réunion ils n'ont pas compris
comment les choses sont arrivées ils
n'ont pas compris notre capacité de
transversalité ils n'ont pas compris
cette capacité que nous avions à
mobiliser autant des gens dans l'espace
africain et diasporique que des gens au
sein du prolétariat français parce que
c'est c'est une spécificité quand même
qu'on doit mettre en avant ils auraient
voulu qu'on soit dans un panafricanisme
justement antiblanc comme ilsst essayer
de nous présenter et cetera et il voit
ça marcheiste noir voilà c'est leur
nouvelle invention alors on est passé en
terme de narratif du Black Power du
pouvoir noir qui a un concept
idéologique créé notamment par stocklic
car Michael qui a un concept idéologique
qui signifie la réappropriation pour les
population noire et afrodescendante de
leur propre destinée sur le terrain
économique politique et social et il y a
eu un glissement sur le terrain du
narratif ce même Black Power au 21e
siècle onappelle suprémacist noir et
c'est comme ça qu'il nous qualifie bon
et ils auraient voulu nous présenter
comme antiblanc ça les aur arranger sauf
que ils sont fâchés quand ils voient
dans nos mobilisations qu'il y a des
prolétaires blancs qui viennent aussi
assister à nos mobilisations nos meeting
et qui sont solidaires de nos causes
parce qu'ils savent qu'on est solidaire
de la leure et euh je pense imaginez
leur stress je le comprends dès l vous
avez vu avec vous avez été vu avec les
Russes puis pas n'importe lesquel avec
les Iraniens avec les
vzuéiens le le le hzbollah avec le
hzbollah aussi bien sûr avec des Chinois
non pas encore pas encore il y a pas
beaucoup de noir en Chine non c'est ça
il y en a à ganzu il y en a pas mal donc
c'est prévu d'ailleurs le le le service
de renseignement il voit Kemy Seba qui
frayille avec tous ces gens-là peut-être
qu'il reçoit de l'argent on a dit du
moins la presse ou d'autres on dit que
vous aviez reçu 300 ou 400000 € de de
main entre guillemets du diable donc ils
peuvent aussi avoir des des des
suspicionss alors après on parlera
est-ce qu'ils ont fait une enquête
est-ce qu'ils sont rentrés dans le
détail est-ce qu'ils vous ont monitoré
infiltré pas infiltré est-ce qu'ils ont
des sources à gauche ou à droite
mettez-vous à leur
place je pense qu'on est un bug dans la
matrice parce qu'ils nous ont vu vous
savez au 21e siècle les populations
noires sont censées être en Occident
contonné à la question de l'antiracisme
tu es raciste tu es pas raciste tu es
méchant tu es pas méchant et cetera on
arrivait avec un logiciel qui était
complètement différent beaucoup plus
radical dans la forme quand on est é
jeune parce que aussi confronté à à une
réalité que nous subissions nous avions
décidé de nous défendre avec les armes
que nous avions à l'époque à notre
disposition céit plusile peut-être non
je ne le qualifierais pas comme ça mais
je dirais qu'on
était on était très véhément en
adéquation avec notre âge j'ai commencé
très jeune j'ai commencé à 18 ans
l'activisme politique à une époque où
les gens vont en boîte de nuit et cetera
moi c'était le combat politique et
c'était défendre les intérêts de nos
populations une radicalité réelle de
jeunesse qui par la suite am mué en une
analyse de classe sur les problématiques
qui touchaient nos populations dans la
diaspora et sur le continent et je me
suis rendu compte qu'il y avait une
transversalité en ce qui concerne
justement cette injustice sociale qui
touchait nos populations et qui touchait
aussi des prolétariats du monde entier
même si il y a des spécificités réelles
en ce qui concerne les populations
africaines et les populations
afro-iasporiques qu'on ne peut pas nier
et le fait qu'on on est ils nous ont vu
au départ comme des leaders de
grospuscules noirs radicaux et PU
non qui prenaient l'autodéfense mais
pour eux quand quand on est attaqué
contre certaines milices et qu'on se
défend ils appellent ça de la violence
ça peut s'entendre et par la suite il
ils ont commencé à nous voir voyager en
avant ça vous avez été dissous on a été
dissous oui on a été dissous sur ce que
j'appelleraiis un rogliot
juridique qui objectivement n'était
était indécent on a été dissous parce
qu'on s'est attaqué on va pas revenir
sur ça pour la milè fois mais parce
qu'on a répondu euh à des milices
extrémistes sionistes qui avaient
tabassé des Noirs lors de manifestations
et en commémoration de la mort d'Ilan
Alimi le Béard la LDJ qui ont l'habitude
de terroriser tout le monde on avait
décidé lorsque ils avaient insulté et
tabassé un certain nombre de noirs de
rendre visite à ces milices qui nous
avaient donné rendez-vous et lorsqu'on
est venu leur rendre visite et qu'ils
ont fui ils ont appelé papa Sarkozi à
l'époque c'est comme ça qu'on on
l'interprète en tout cas Sarkozi était
en pleine campagne à cette époque et a
décidé de nous dissoudre c'est comm
comme ça que les choses sont passées ça
s'est pas passé autrement je ferme la
parenthèse parce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'autres choses qui sont passées et les
voyages qu'on a effectué au quatre coins
du monde auprès de nations qui
s'opposent à l'impérialisme et à
l'hégémonie du globalisme néolibéral et
dans des nations de où il y a des
populations de toutes les couleurs on a
été dans le monde arabe on a été au
Proche Orient Moyen-Orient on a été en
Amérique du Sud on a été on peut pas
faire plus blanc que l'Europe de l'Est
je pense
objectivement ça nous a permis d'avoir
une une vision globale et d'approfondir
notre
perception sur les les rapports de
domination entre une petite élite de
toutes les couleurs en réalité et une
majorité de la population de toutes les
couleurs beaucoup du Sud global
objectivement mais pas que qui
commençaiit à en avoir marre de cette
hégémonie qui avait décidé de
s'organiser ça a élargi nos horizons et
ça nous a pas mis nous organiser avec
beaucoup plus de de force de lucidité de
distance critique sur un certain nombre
de sujets toujours ant enraaciné sur la
la défense de nos populations mais on a
compris qu'on à partir du moment où on
lutte contre le néolibéralisme
économique et sociétal on ne lutte pas
que pour notre peuple on lutte pour
notre peuple en priorité mais on lutte
pour tous ceux qui sont opprimés en
réalité et je pense que c'est important
qu'on puisse le rappeler et je pense que
c'est cette addition de facteur le fait
qu'il nous voit à gauche à droite qui
nous voit prendre en audience on a
commencé on était suivi par des
vingtaines ou des trentaines de
personnes on est aussi aujourd'hui suivi
par des millions de gens c'est quelque
chose qui inquiète évidemment il nous
voit organiser des mobilisations des
meetings au quatre coins du monde et
surtout en Afrique ou dans les
territoires d'outr mer ont réuni des
foules importantes c'est financé comment
par qui qu'on soit très clair au départ
ça a été financé je lui rends hommage ça
été soutenu par des footballeurs
notamment Nicolas Anelka d'accord euh je
peux le dire c'est pas un secret Nicolas
Anelka et quelques autres les frères
Fati et quelques autres qui ont très tôt
compris le le combat que nous menons ça
a été aussi financé par des artistes
dont certains sont encore en première
ligne aujourd'hui des rappeurs et cetera
que je dont je ne citerai pas les noms
et par la suite on s'est organisé pour
trouver auprès d'opérateurs économique
africain et un certain nombre de gens
qui se sont touchés par le combat les
soutiens et après par la suite par des
voyages et des missions géopolitique de
notre organisation dans le cadre du Sud
global on s'est rapproché de gens qui
étaient très impressionnés par
l'audience que nous avons notamment a
plusieurs pays par exemple on a mené une
action sociale importante humanitaire on
a été soutenu à l'époque la Turquie nous
a soutenu nous a accompagné c'était du
côté d'Haïti la la Turquie le pouvoir
central une on local financé par le
pouvoir central qui non des gens autour
du pouvoir central qui on on propose des
des projets sur le terrain sociétal sur
le terrain humanitaire ils se sentent
touchés par ce que l'on fait et ils
savent que il est mieux d'être en bonne
relation avec des gens comme nous parce
que aujourd'hui quoi qu'on en dise euh
quand vous êtes un leader d'opinion que
c'est quantifiable que vous représentez
quelque chose vous êtes une source
d'attraction pour certains pays qui ont
pour volonté par exemple de pouvoir par
la suite devenir des partenaires
commerciaux ou économiques avec certains
pays c'est comme ça que ça se passe
est-ce que aussi il positionneraiit leur
futur petit pion c'est difficile de de
parler de petit pion parce que ceux qui
nous connaissent dans ces pays vous le
diront de manière très simple qu'on est
profondément ingérable c'est le surnom
qu'on nous donne parfois et j'irai plus
loin en vous disant que on est considéré
comme opignatre on est très accroché à
notre perception à nos visions du monde
et ça crée parfois des clashes ça crée
parfois des désaccords mais ils savent
qu'on est des forces sur lesquelles ils
sont obligés de compter eux tous et
c'est pour ça que donc je donne un autre
exemple ma question avait pour but de
vous la poser la question est-ce que
vous avez eu l'impression de vous faire
instrumentaliser par Pierre Paul Jacques
Mohamed ou ce que vous
voulez et est-ce que vous avez eu
l'impression qu'il se positionner vous
financer pour pouvoir ensuite vous
contrôler ou vous demander un retour
d'ascenseur je connais votre caractère
je sais je sais que vous
connaissez je sais que vous êtes une
tête de bois que votre cause c'est tout
pour vous la question que je vous pose
c'est est-ce que vous avez senti qu'il
cherchait à vous instrumentaliser on va
être très clair il y a eu parfois euh
certains dans certains voyages des gens
qui au départ euh se sont dit ont essayé
en disant ça serait bien qu'on puisse
mener des activités sur tel et on leur a
dit non nous on a not on a notre agenda
comme le disait Nelson MondeLa lorsqu'il
était dans cette bataille de libération
de notre population du côté de l'Afrique
du Sud avec la NC la NC est partie
chercher des financements chez les
Soviétiques ils sont NC c'est c'est
l'Africain National Congress donc le
mouvement de Nelson Mandela qui a porté
Mandela au pouvoir qui a lutté contre la
Paride l'ANC est parti chercher des
financements chez Khaddafi ils sont
partis chercher des financements chez
les Soviétiques c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui la Russie a de très
bonnes relations notamment avec
l'Afrique du Sud et ce qui est
intéressant à souligner dans ce casadre
là c'est que à l'époque Mandela était
taxé d'agent et laanc était taxé de
mouvements prbien ou de mouvements
proviétique et cetera et cetera à cause
de ces liens-là mais c'est pas parce
qu'on mène un combat et qu'on cherche
des financements à gauche à droite que
cela signifie qu'on devient les agents
des des partenaires que l'on a non
Mandela l'a bien dit on cherche des
soutiens là où on peut le trouver pour
mener à bien nos causes parce qu'on est
contre des systèmes oppressifs qui qui
regorge d'un certain nombre de richesses
qui ont tous les moyens coercitifs et
les moyens financiers et on doit être
capable par la suite de chercher autour
des entités qui se reconnaissent dans
notre combat et qui pour x ou y raison
ont tout intérêt à ce que notre combat
avance ne soyons pas bêt quand quelqu'un
vous finance ou vous soutient d'une
façon ou d'une autre c'est parce qu'ils
y trouvent eux aussi leur intérêt mais
le plus important c'est que nous dans le
cadre du combat que nous menons on reste
fixé sur notre ligne et je donne un
exemple très précis le le travail que
mne une urgence panafricaniste qui peut
êre qui peut être êt considéré comme
étant tripartitionnel lutte pour la
promotion de lajustice sociale lutte
contre la corruption de nos élites et
contre la malgouvernance et lutte contre
le néocolonialisme tant que ça ne sort
pas de ce cadre làà on a aucun problème
si un tel dit qu'il veut nous soutenir
sur tel tel tel tel facteur du moment
que les partenaires en question soi dans
ce cadre de la multipolarité et opposé à
l'hégémonie de l'élite globaliste
dégénérée néolibéral ah bah ça peut
peut-être les les arranger que vous
menassiez les intérêts français parce
qu'ils ont décidé de défendre de de
dégager les Français j'entends
parfaitement votre question sauf que
c'est pas les intérêts français dont il
s'agit on dénonce et on lutte contre le
Fran CFA contre les bases militaires
contre la cooptation de nos élites par
l'oligarchie putride putrifié français
et le dire c'est pas manquer de respect
il y a des gilets jaunes qui ont des
propos bien plus durs et lourds
vis-à-vis de de leurs autorités et à
aucun moment on a fait je pense faire
partie des rares et parmi les plus
audibles et je pense est aujourd'hui
dans cette galaxie le plus audible euh
je pense faire partie des rares qui ont
toujours fait cette dichotomie entre
oligarchie française et prolétariat
français parce que je vois de mes
propres yeux la manière dont le la
population française elle-même est
écrasée par sa population on parle de
coup d'État en Afrique mais ce qui s'est
passé récemment avec Emmanuel Macron qui
perd les élections donc il faut qu'on se
dise des choses très clairement tu crois
que tu es venu pour pousser un caddi ou
c'est une évidence c'est une
réalité la gauche quoi qu'on puisse
donner comme critique vis-à-vis de et
j'ai un certain nombre de remarques à
faire sur un certain nombre d'aspects
même si de manière naturelle je suis
plus à gauche qu'on le veille ou pas que
qu'à droite c'est juste que la gauche a
une attitude paternaliste très ancré en
France que je ne trouve pas dans
d'autres endroits du monde notamment du
côté de l'Espagne où on a été reçu par
podemos on y reviendra après où j'ai vu
une démarche de solidarité qui est
beaucoup plus en adéquation avec le
combat de justice sociale que mène notre
organisation agence panafricaniste mais
la gauche a gagné les élections mais la
gauche s'est fait banané il y a un coup
d'état institutionnel donc on on est
dans un pays en France où vous êtes dans
un pays où l'oligarchie n fait qu'à sa
tête se comporte de manière coloniale
vis-à-vis même de sa propre population
de la France périférique notamment donc
les campagnes mais aussi des banlieux et
donc ne nous attendons pas à ce qu'ils
aient notre démche pourque à sa tête
selon vous je pense que les intérêts de
de l'élite néolibérale française sont
les intérêts de l'élite néolibérale
globale en tant que tel et que la France
est un département dans ce village monde
qu'ils veulent constituer et ils ont un
mépris ils considèrent la population
française comme des S de la même façon
qu'il considèr de manière bien pire
d'ailleurs les populations africaines du
continent ou de la diaspora dans les
territoires d'outr mer comme des seres
il suffit de voir comment Macron se
comporte avec le le son propre peuple
pour comprendre qu'il y a une
déconnexion profonde les gens qui ne
sont rien oui mais c'est et il est pas
le premier je veux dire qu'avant lui
Hollande disait quand on parlait
descendant quand on parlait d'un certain
nombre de de de de terminologie que je
veux pas redonner ici mais on est
vraiment je même à l'époque de la
royauté je suis pas sûr que les rois
parlaient de cette façon de leur propre
peuple je suis pas certain les guux et
les Manon oui mais je veux dire à la
limite ils avaient une couronne qui
pouvait leur laisser croire que ils sont
foutés de ce que le peuple pense alors
que là ces dirigeants sont censés être
élus et ils sont censés être élus mais
il se comportent comme des gens qui ont
des comptes à rendre à une élite mais
certainement pas à leur population donc
on s'éloigne un petit peu du curseur
mais tout ça pour dire que on il y a en
France une une élite qui est aveuglée
par son sa propre déconnexion déjà
vis-à-vis de sa propre baseenir là-dus
revenons à aux sources de
financement avec qui comment et comment
c'est décrit avec qui vous frayez ou qui
vous instrumentalise ou qui vous utilise
personne n instrumentalise si ce n'est
Dieu et et on reviendra sur Dieu plus
tard d'ailleurs il y a pas de souci on
revient sur tout ce que sur tout ce que
vous voulez il y a pas de problème
j'espère bien mince mais question les
volumes financiers qui transit sur les
comptes en banque de votre association
sur vos comptes en banque ça représente
quoi vous avez besoin de combien d'euros
pour fonctionner par mois vous avez
combien de salariés
combien je mène ce combat depuis 25 ans
depuis
1999 tu avais 19 ans ouais j'avais 18
ans quand j'ai commencé je suis né en
fin d'année donc j'avais 18 ans et j'en
ai aujourd'hui
42 tu es bien tu es bien conservé quand
même par la grâce de Dieu on va dire je
remercie mes parents pour ça merci je on
a mené notre combat pendant 90 % du
temps avec
rien c'est important qu'on le dise on a
mené une campagne historique contre le
Fran CFA et les bases militaires en 2017
avec rien quand je te dis rien c'était
les les tontines ceux qui connaissent en
Afrique chacun met chacun met chacun met
chacun met ça tourne ça tourne ça tourne
on met et cetera pour s'en sortir on a
mené avec rien et c'est parce que
urgence panafricaniste a eu un succès
historique à travers cette campagne de
2017 qu'on a attiré le regard de bon
nombre de d'endroits de pays du Sud
global qui sont dit eux ce sont des gens
à accompagner et soutenir parce qu'ils
représente une force politique et une
force sociale qu'on n pas vu depuis très
longtemps c'est comme ça que les choses
sont déroulées on était déjà lié au
Venezuela à l'Iran diplomatiquement
j'étais très proche de l'ambassadeur de
d'Iran et du Venezuela Sénégal à
l'époque où j'étais journaliste pour
tout te dire c'est comme ça que ça a
commencé en fait je suis chroniqueur
géopolitique à l'époque sur la première
chaîne privée du Sénégal la des TV et
donc mon rôle c'est d'interviewer
différentes personnalités et notamment
des ambassadeurs ça fait du bien de se
retrouver en face là de se faire
interviewer ça fait drôle mais disons
que voilà
j'étais j'interagissais avec beaucoup de
gens du Sud global et moi j'avais déjà
ma stratégie mon objectif la télé
c'était pas une FA en soi c'était un
outil Ramsi parlait de la bataille
culturelle mon objectif était de me
servir des mass médias en Afrique pour
rendre mainstream quelque chose qui
était pendant un temps devenu désué
élitiste il y a des gens qui vont parler
de panafricanisme mais il ils ont un
langage tellement pédant et tellement
abscon il y en a qu'ils sont inaudibles
pour la masse moi mon objectif était de
rendre le panafricanisme euh comment
dirais-je intelligible pour le grand
grand grand public en Afrique
francophone et dans la diaspora et parce
que ferud géopolitique et pas ferud
géopolitique dans son acception
sorbonard mais dans son dans son
acception de terrain dans sa
compréhension de terrain c'est-à-dire
que c'est de l'expérience que tu tires
aussi ta science ta
connaissance en frayant un certain
nombre d'amitiés avec des députés duant
en cultivant si tu le souhaites des des
amitiés avec des ambassadeurs du Sud
global on s'est retrouvé à commencer à
voyager à différents endroits à visiter
qui payit les les voyages bah ceux qui
nous invitaent c'est que si on invité en
IR payis ton billet la moitié du billet
d'avion la moié de je veux pas si tu
m'invites tu m'invites à anniversaire je
mais si c'est mon anniversaire voilà
donc si c'est mon anniversaire je
t'invite et puisé j'éta' invité à
l'anniversaire de par contre quand nous
on a été invité chez les Russes avec le
coloc sur le le terrorisme ainsi de
suite il payent le billet d'avion nous
on payé la chambre d'hôutel 5050 pour
préserver préserver bah fact préserver
la distance entre eux on nous achète pas
ben moi tu peux me payer la chambre tu
peux me payer le voyage c'est pas demain
la veille que tu vas acheter ma façon de
penser et tu m'entenderas jamais faire
la pomme pom girl d'autres entités que
de ma cê de Pom Pom c'est certain dis de
Pom Pom boy non plus mais mais je ne
suis pas ce qu'est Macron pour l'élite
no libérale c'était gratuit mais je
comprends quand on sait sa place dans
l'oligarchie no libérale je suis pas sûr
que ça soit très gratuit mais fermons la
parenthèse
euh donc céta fin donc on est invité et
donc nous nos conditions sont très
précises tel membr du staff on est
combien on est tel tel tel on est tel
autel collation et cetera et notre
liberté P question question euh vous
étiez invité à faire un speech très
souvent à faire un speech bien sûr dans
des conférences et C c'était considéré
comme des frais le fait qu'on paye la
note d'hôtel et et la vi conférencier en
tantinvenant et bien sû en tant que
consultant est-ce que vous receviez un
chèque de consultant en plus de l'hôtel
de billets d'avion est-ce que votre
chambre était garnie garnie c'estàd ah
bah c'est une vieille expression je vois
l'expérience mais oh c'est gratuit en ce
que tu entends par garni bah est-ce
qu'on avait des cadeaux sur le lit des
cadeaux dans le tiroir
franchement à part à part les boissons
les jus les chocolats dans le frigo
c'est V c'est vrai que tu bois pas
d'alcool non je bois pas d'alcool et à
part ça on avait rien on avait rien du
tout et le consult il y avait un chèque
pour rembourser le consultant non
parfois tu vas dans des pays où ça t pas
ça tit pas ça n'est pas à l'ordre du
jour il a des endroits où on impose
d'avoir des cachets pour not prise de
parole ça dépend c'est très variable
fourchette non c'est trop variable pour
que une fourchette ça peut être 500 € il
y a des conférences que j'ai pu faire
dans le monde où j'avais pas envie d'y
aller j'ai monté les taraux il voulaaiit
m'avoir on m j'ai pu être payé pour un
discours 3000 € des trucs de ce style là
max
ouais ça va entre ça et ça en fait moi
j'ai pas cher quand même bah clairement
il y a des gens ça va être des 20000
pour des cachets et cetera Sarkozi c'est
combien je sais pas en mais c'est c'est
encore plus mais
moi j'ai j'ai un côté très
anticapitaliste en vrai est-ce que tu
comprends pourquoi je veux avoir j'ai
pas de souci avec ça je comprends mais
il sera difficile que je te donne un
chiffre parce que je suis on a invité
partout et on a invité partout on a fait
des milliers de conférences le
fonctionnement de laass H c'est combien
combien de salariés combien payer c'est
pas quel c'est du droit français du
droit B droit africain c'est une
organisation africaine qui a été créé au
Sénégal qui s'est déployé ensuite dans
toute l'Afrique francophone et qui a
donc un mode de fonctionnement en tant
que mouvement de libération et
d'autodétermination qui est spécifique à
nos réalités en Afrique on a pas très
cher non c'est bruit c'est le système D
était notre première base de financement
tous les mouvements citoyens te le
diront c'est comme ça qu'on fonctionne
et quand on réussi à avoir des budget à
gauche à droite on avance mais
contrairement à ce qu'on on nous
raconte ce qu'on entend il y a des
fantasmes sur nous je l'ai vu quand on a
été arrêté par les services secrets on
en parlera après on entend dire que tu
es un mercenaire oui que tu prends
300000 balles que tu prends 400000
balles et que ça vient de tel pays
hostile c'est vrai c'est pas vrai est-ce
qu'il y a eu des chiffres comme ça ils
ont aucune preuve il y a que des sources
ouver preuve parce qu'ils l'ont pas
trouvé ou ils ontcune precune preuve de
ça de un et il y en aura pas je vais te
préciser des choses c'est important je
pense que si j'avais travaillé pour
George Soros ou pour l'Agence française
de développement ou pour usid on aura
dit que je suis un chevalier du
développement et un homme très
consciencieux mais comme j'ai décidé de
travailler pour mon peuple et de
travailler contre le globalisme
néolibéral et de travailler à la
solidarité des prolétariats du monde
entier je deviens un mercenaire des
états ennemi entre guillemets ennemi de
la des autorités françaises je dis bien
entre guillemets parce que de manière
très simple il y a des pays avec
lesquels il nous accuse d'avoir
collaboré d'avoir décidé d'avancer
durant un temps mais ces pays-là
eux-même ils interagissaient avec eux au
moment où ben je donne un exemple simple
la Russie on a commencé à interagir avec
les Russes on va dire en 2018 fin 2017
mais surtout décembre 2017 fin de
l'année mais surtout 2018 mais en 2018
les autorités françaises
elles étaient en interaction avec les
Russes donc quand en gros les [__]
excuse-moi mais ben non mais chez nous
quand nous on l'utilise c'est pas pareil
que quand vous l'utilisez il y a un côté
comme disait M céser quand l'homme noir
utilise le terme [__] il sait
d'utiliser de manière améliorative mais
d'où la notion de négritude aussi
mais les autorités françaises étaient en
interaction avec les Russes en 2018
pourquoi quand nous on interagissait
avec eux c'était un problème et quand
eux le faisaient c'était pas un problème
je pense qu'il faut quand même qu'on se
pose des questions en gros tout le monde
a le droit de faire la géopolitique mais
pas nous quand nous on se rapproche de
Venezuela quand nous on décide de se
rapprocher de Cuba quand nous on décide
de se rapproch Cuba avec le avec pays
avec lequel les autorités françaises ont
rapport convenable il faut aussi qu'on
le dise en tout cas à l'époque où nous
on a commencé il était très convenable
euh avec l'Iran peut-être un petit peu
moins mais c'est pas un pays déclaré
comme étant pays ennemi non plus ici que
c'est toujours dit l'axe du mal quand
même c'est par les Américains et par
leur caniche et si maintenant les
autorités françaises décident de se
comporter comme les caniches de
l'oligarchie américaine c'est leur droit
mais en tout cas nous on a décidé de
faire des partenariat dans cette
architecture mondiale il y avait depuis
l'effondrement du mur de Berlin le bloc
de l'Ouest est devenu hégémonique le
capitalisme a connu son ultime
métamorphose à travers le néolibéralisme
le plus dérégulé sur sa forme économique
et sociétale sur la forme économique
c'est devenu hégémonique mais sur la
forme sociétale que certains appellent
le progressisme
dérégulé il il y a commencé il a
commencé à avoir au début du 21e siècle
un certain nombre de résistance on va
dire à différents endroits du monde en
disant simplement que l'American way of
life l'occidentalisation du monde c'est
pas quelque chose qui est valable
partout c'est pas acceptable partout et
donc euh dans ces pays-là ces pays-là
sont devenus très sensibles à la
question de la colonialité donc les
mouvements qui résiste à cette
colonialité à ce colonialiste le plus
putréfié ben de à partir du moment où
ils ont audiance si tu es groupusculaire
où tu parles dans ta cabine téléphonique
ça pas marché mais si tu commences à
être aible d'une masse critique là
forcément tu deviens un interlocuteur
parfois même plus audible que certains
dirigeants d'État il faut qu'on se le
dise en toute sincérité j'ai été invité
parfois dans des parlements dans
certains pays où il y avait des
dirigeants que ce soit en Iran que ce
soit en Russie où il y avait des
dirigeants qui de pays africains qui
était un au poste des ministres et
cetera qui étaient dans le public et
nous on était les speakers ça ce sont
des choses qui sont du domaine du
factuel parce que aujourd'hui nous
sommes les leaders d'opinion que
certains leaders institutionnels ne sont
pas mais on va on va te reprocher d'être
l'idiot utile d'une puissance béliqueuse
idot utile quand tu sers les intérêts
des autres tu sers pas les tiens mais
quand tu sers les tiens en priorité et
que d'autres maintenant décident
partiellement de surfit dessus qui est
l'idiot utile de qui l'erreur c'est de
toujours penser que quand l'Afrique
quand l'Africain décide de rentrer dans
une dynamique géopolitique il est
toujours l'idiootutile de quelqu'un nous
on mène notre combat je donne un exemple
simple pour terminer le propos
excuse-moi euh je mets au défi des gens
de trouver une longue période durant
laquelle je dis les Russes sont les
meilleurs les Russes sont les meilleurs
les Russes sont les meilleurs les
Iraniens sont les meilleurs les Iraniens
ça n'arrivera jamais il y en a d'autres
qui le font il y en a d'autres en
Afrique qui le font non je vais pas
citer de nom je suis pas je pas faire
drooping sur ce terrainl et cetera je ne
le fais pas pour la simple raison que
personne ne me fera dire que les Russes
sont les messis des Africains que les
Iraniens sont les messis des africains
ou que qui que ce soit d'autre que les
Africains sont les messis de leur propre
destinée et je suis très conscient du
qu'il existe dans les pays précités
comme partout dans le monde en réalité
mais dans ces pays c'est aussi exposé
une négrophobie à certains endroits
qu'on ne peut pas nier non plus donc je
ne suis pas bête pour croire ça et quand
j'interagis avec des des entités il y a
un rapport qui est très précis ils
savent que à travers moi il parl un un
un pan non négligeable de la jeunesse
d'Afrique francophone et des territoires
d'outre m aujourd'hui et donc ils savent
qu'il est important pour eux qu'ils a un
comportement qui soit digne il y a des
gens que l'élite occidentale trouve
super méchante mais avec lesquelles on a
eu l'occasion de d'échanger de de
discuter et qui ont été très gentil avec
nous je je vais me faire l'avocat du
diable tu aimes bien le diable on dirait
j'aime pas le diable tu connais le
proverbe malien qui dit quand tu te
couches avec le diable le lendemain
matin tu sens encore le diable je conis
pas mais tu me l' prends ok c'était en
référence à la Zaw et au qui avait fait
une alliance avec avec plusieurs mouvs
Islamist ok avec les TF on dit ils
avaient pas apprécié du tout ok on
reviendra sur la question de terrorisme
en Afrique pour revenir arrête de me
faire perdre mon fil c'est pas c'est pas
volontaire on voit que tu es un
professionnelour professionnel qui se
rencontre alors on va dire ça vas-y
bienvenue quand je dis idiot utile h tu
pousses les anciens maîtres avec tout le
respect que je te dois bien sûr tu
pousses tes anciens maîtres dehors
est-ce que tuen changes pas tu changes
pas tes anciens maîtres par de nouveaux
maîtres sans même t'en rendre compte tu
sais je vais te donner un exemple je
comprends très bien ta question et ma
réponse va être très fluide com question
euh cette année lorsque j'étais au bkina
Faso parce que c'est c'est devenu
aujourd'hui un signe de provocation
comme un peu dans le monde arabe euh
certains brandissaient le drapeau de de
Ben Laden ou des portraits de Ben Laden
à une certaine époque pour contester la
présence américaine ça veut pas dire
qu'ils étaient amoureux de Ben Laden
mais c'était selon eux une façon de
dénoncer à une certaine époque hein
l'hégémonie américaine la présence
américaine sur leur sol aujourd'hui il y
a en Afrique dans certains pans de la
société des gens qui brandissent des
drapeaux russes pour déranger la
présence française les trouve vous les
drapeau il les cous je conis il les cous
eux-même et je peux te dire
objectivement que la plupart de ce que
moi je vois ce que j'ai vu je sais
qu'ils sont pas payés pour le faire en
plus c'est ça le pire est-ce qu'ils
reçoivent pas un petit kit de parf
réolnaire je pense pas eux objectivement
j'ai j'ai j'ai vu des gens qui le
faisaient et on a eu des discussions je
fais partie des rares qui disent que
c'est que je trouve que c'est une
humiliation quand on mène des
mobilisations pour la souveraineté que
de devoir brandir des drapeaux russes
moi je trouve pas que c'est pertinent on
brandit les drapeaux de nos pays à la
limite le drapeau rouge noir vert du
panafricanisme il y a pas de souci mais
brandir les drapeaux d'un autre pays ça
me pose problème je l'ai dit j'ai eu des
tensions avec certains ministres euh non
je je Mme pas leur donner de publicité
il n'en mérit pas mais c'est une réalité
je l'ai fait donc on peut pas m'accuser
moi et je sais même que dans ces pays-là
on me considère et je le répète comme le
le le leader
panafricaniste un peu ingérable un peu
insupportable dans le sens où ce qui
l'intéresse c'est sa propre cause
uniquement et je ne le cache pas je suis
centré sur les intérêts de mes
populations de nos populations de nos
semblables sur les intérêts de l'Afrique
et sur les intérêts de sa diaspora donc
je mène un combat qu'on a commencé à une
époque où que ce soit les Iraniens que
ce soit les Russes que ce soit les
vézuéliens ou autres vézuéliens à la
limite c'est encore autre chose mais les
deux premiers cités il se préoccupaient
même pas de la réalité africaine c'est
une réalité donc dire que on est dans
une démarche de suivre leurs intérêts ou
d'être des mercenaires de leur cause
alors que la seule cause que l'on défend
c'est la autre c'est objectivement pas
sérieux que de l'énoncer je le pense
profondément maintenant ne nous montons
pas à partir du moment où on est assez
capable de comment dirais-je faire
reculer l'hégémonie occidentale sur le
continent africain forcément quand il y
a des angles morts il y a d'autres qui
vont s'enouffrer dedans et qui vont et
qui vont essayer de devenir des nouveaux
partenaires plac des places libres il y
a des places libre mais des places
librees pourquoi c'est ça la question
place libre pour être des nouveaux
maîtres certainement pas parce que la
manière dont on est en train de former
la nouvelle génération africaine et ce
qui est certain c'est que c'est pas
demain la veille que des gens vont venir
se comporter vis-à-vis de nos
populations comme des pilleurs et si ça
le fait si ça se fait de cette façon ils
auront en face une réaction je veux dire
si on a été capable de faire reculer la
présence néocoloniale de l'oligarchie je
dis bien pas le peuple de l'oligarchie
française qui a une expérience du
continent africain bien plus rigoureuse
et sérieuse objectivement et et
connaissance que les Russes dis aussi
les choses c'est pas les Russes ou les
Iraniens qu'on aura du mal s'il décident
un jour de se comporter autrement que
comme ils le font actuellement
c'està-dire des partenaires c'est pas le
russes ou les Chinois ou les Iraniens
qui ne goûteront pas à la contestation
africaine en tant que telle mais dans le
en l'état dans l'état actuel des faits
et des choses aujourd'hui c'est pas
c'est pas le cas il faut qu'on
partenariat winwin gagnant gagnant bien
sûr les Chinois c'est gagnant gagnant en
Afrique écout tu sais la Chine la Chine
il y a une vraie diabolisation que je ne
vois objectivement en Europe ou aux
États-Unis de la Chine qui qu'on soit
très clair hein moi j'ai beaucoup de
choses aussi à à reprocher j'ai été très
offensif j'en ai parlé avec certains
ambassadeurs chinois aussi j'étais très
offensif quand il y avait des dérives de
certains chefs d'entreprise chinoisees
sur le continent africain qui se
comportaient avec des ouvriers africains
d'une manière qui dépassait
l'entendement moi j'ai lancé des des
campagnes en faisant comprendre aux
Chinois que s'il continuaient comme ça
ils allaient devoir très rapidement
rentrer à shanghï on m'acusé d'être un
leader xénophobe antichinois et cetera
moi je suis habitué à toutes ces bêtises
là j'ai dit non on n'est pas xénophobe
mais s'il y a des dérives de quel qu'on
part que ce soit on va les dénoncer de
la même façon que ce soit la Russie on a
assisté parfois dans certaines zones
notamment en centra-frique il y a des
choses moi qui ne m'ont pas plu j'ai dit
aux Russes que ces choses-là ce sont des
choses qui ne sont pas convenables et
qu'il faut faire attention et je l'ai
dit au à H guimo University qui est le
Harvard russe où j'étais invité à faire
une conférence où je l'ai dit au
Parlement russe à la Douma que
attention on trace des partenariats
mais ne pensez pas que partenaire
signifie devenir nouveau maître qui va
remplacer l'ancienne entité qui nous a
colonisé parce que si vous rentrez dans
cette dynamique là vous nous trouverez
sur votre chemin quand on dit ça
certains se disent mais kemiseba c'est
et leur groupe panafricanistme sous
prétexte qu'ils sont populaires ils sont
très arrogants ils pensent qu'ils
peuvent renverser des pays puissants
n'oubliez jamais que le Vietnam a réussi
à faire tomber la première puissance
mondiale avec d'autres aides et d'autres
dans d'autres circonstances en effet euh
qui était les États-Unis n'oubliez pas
que les États-Unis qui était derrière ah
tiens qui était à côté derrière c'est un
grand mot mais qui les accompagné mais
c'était surtout aussi dû en réalité à la
détermination des Viet con qu'on le
veille ou pas parce qu'un peuple mort il
peut avoir tous les partenaire du monde
s'il se prend pas en charge ça va pas
marcher de la même façon qu'en
Afghanistan les Américains toutpuissants
n'ont pas réussi à gérer et les Russes
aussi ils n pas sponsorisé les Russes
qui qui ont sponsorisé les les les les
talibans ou avant eux les Américains qui
sponsorisai les tout donc c'est pour te
dire que il y a aucune puissance qui est
imbattable bon
revenons
financier combien tu gagnes c'est y a
rien de régulier on se débrouille entre
combien et combien j'ai pas de
fourchette des fois ça peut être on peut
se débrouiller pour avoir des opérateurs
économiques là récemment on a eu un un
opérateur
économique d'un pays d'Afrique de
l'Ouest que je ne citerai pas qui fait
partie de ceux qui résistent qui a
décidé de nous sout voilà combien non
j'ai pas de j'ai pas de Somme à te
donner combien tu gagnes toi j'ai pas de
Somme don la déclaration d'impôt elle
est fait où mais moi je vis en Afrique
je déclarer les impôts à qui et bah au
pays où tu résides bah écoute on voyage
dans différents endroits et j'ai pas de
déclaration d'impôts à faire je suis un
combattant de la liberté qui se bat pour
son peuple et on survit des fois on est
dans des des des séquences difficiles
des fois on est dans des séquences où on
s'en sort un peu plus on n'est pas une
organisation milliardaire on n'est pas
une organisation financée par Soros par
la grâce de Dieu mais je peux dire que
les mouvements financés parseros gagne
100 fois plus 1000 fois plus que ce que
nous gagnons avec des petites pécadies
mais on arrive malgré tout à faire des
miracles donc on se débrouille c'est
très fluctuant des fois ça peut être des
fois on peut être dans une euh
difficulté économique incroyable et je
et et et je pèse mes mots vraiment et
des fois on peut être dans une situation
qui est convenable qui est loin de ce
que gagnent les mastodons des mouvements
citoyens en Afrique qui ont moins
d'audience que nous mais qui ont plus de
moyens que nous mais ça nous empêche pas
d'avancer tu as une fortune personnelle
aucune c'est quoi il y a combien sur ton
compte en banque je vais pas te répondre
mais déjà bon courage à ceux qui vont me
trouver un compte en banque voilà tu tu
utilises le
Bitcoin moi je suis un homme du troc je
suis un Africain
traditionnaliste revenons à ton
interpellation raconte-moi un petit peu
comment ça s'est passé où quand comment
quelle date éout j'étais ça a fait
l'objet de beaucoup de discussions au
sein de mon organisation pourquoi
j'étais bon à la base de par mon
passeport diplomatique j'avais un ordre
de mission pour des questions relatives
aux migrations de quel pays
donc les autorités du nigerre m'ont
donné un ordre de mission pour des
questions relatives aux migrations en
Espagne d'accord donc j'y suis allé et
en dehors de ça j'avais des rendez-vous
puisque j'ai un visa Schengen de longue
durée euh délivré par qui délivré par un
pays de l'Union européenne qui est en
relation avec les autorités du Niger
dont je suis proche et euh donc donc
j'ai été à différents endroits voir des
opposants béninois au président Patrice
Talon ça c'était en dehors de mon cadre
entre guillemets diplomatique
et considéré comme un agent perturbateur
pas du tout non je je des réunion
politique il y a plein il y a plein
d'opposants qui se réunissent partout
dans le monde et qui discutent je vis
dans un pays qui est malheureusement
depuis 2016 devenu une dictature alors
que le Bénin était le pays de la
démocratie entre guillemets depuis 90 et
aujourd'hui on a un un autocrate
considéré comme comme tel par bon nombre
d'observateurs internationaux Patrice
Talon qui euh qui qui est la plus grosse
fortune du pays et qui sur le terrain du
néolibéralisme est en train d'asphyxier
notre population un degré qui dépasse
l'entendement et qui fait de chaque
opposant un exilé politique il faut
qu'on puisse le dire aussi alors que
lui-même pourtant a été exilé à une
époque où il était dans l'opposition
malheureusement il a pas tenu les leçons
de de sa chose bref donc on rencontrit
des opposants politique et je suis
descendu à Paris pour en rencontrer
aussi et pour voir un MRE de ma famille
qui est malade je ne te cache pas que
j'avais pas envie de retourner en France
pour diverses raisons les autorités du
Niger m'avait demandé m'avit conseillé
de ne pas descendre je l'ai fait sur
quatre forces majeures ça a été compris
et donc c'est lors de ce court séjour de
ce micro séjour que les services secrets
ont décidé de nous tomber dessus donc au
sortir d'un d'un restaurant on était
parti manger une F secret français oui a
déjà ire franç ouais la déjà euh donc
ils sont venus à 40 environ je dis 40 à
minima mais c'était vraiment ils ont
bouclé le quartier c'est j'avais vu avec
mes enfants le film messerine euh Merine
ouais bon excuse-moi je prononce pas la
française
mais ce qui s'est passé là là je je
pense qu'on était dans des proportions
au moins similaires c'était n'importe
quoi à tel point qu'il y a une mamie qui
était en état de choc qu'est-ce qui se
passe qu'est-ce que vous faites elle a
vu des gens cagoule venir armé comme si
on était je sais pas ils ont cru qu'on
était l'état islamique c'est marrant ils
n'arrivent pas à arrêter ceux qui font
les attentats mais il ils viennent
surarmé à 40 pour arrêter des gens qui
de manière ouverte et officielle ne pent
pas d'armes bref tu as vu comment tu es
costaud mais alors donc parce queu com
tes potes ils sont costaud mais ça veut
dire pour ça on doit venir armer je
trouve que c'est démesuré et
malheureusement il s'attaque à ceux qui
ne commettent pas d' d'attentat qui ont
pour logiciel depuis un certain nombre
d'années la forcherie depuis que je suis
rentré en Afrique c'est la doctrine de
notre organisation la non violence
politique parce que je pense que
stratégiquement moralement on est
beaucoup plus gagnant en montrant que le
barbare c'est celui qui est violent et
de résister de manière non violente
c'est montrer qu'il y en a un qui est
barbare qui t'attaque par des moyens
irraisonnés et l'autre qui réagit de
manière intelligente donc tu sors du
resto on sort du resto euh je me rends
compte que j'ai oublié mon portable donc
je reviens et je pense que ça a dû
participer à la nervosité des flics des
mes des des services secrets quand ils
nous ont arrêtés n on les appelle les
flics toi de la police il y a pas de
aussi et euh donc je reviens dans
restaurant je ressors et là je vois un
gars deux gars trois gars arrivriver
cagouet bouge pas bouge pas bouge bougez
pas bougez pas bougez pas j'ai même pas
le temps de comprendre il nous plaque
contre le mur côté du du restaurant il
dit bouge bouge pas bouge il commence
les insultes est-ce qu'ils avaient des
signes distinctifs de police un brassard
brassard brassard kagoule en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est que en fait ils
étaient tous dans le quartier je sais
pas si tu as connu la série 21 James
Street mais c'est en grosso modo c'est
un petit peu ça c'est tu as pas connu 21
pas ok il y a pas de souci c'est c'est
une série où c'est des mecs c'est qui se
font dans le décor qui font qui font
semblant d'être ils peuvent boueurs tout
ce que tu veux et cetera et après tu
rends compte que c'est des flics et
c'était ça en fait c'était des gens qui
je pense quand on est rentré dans le
restaurant ils étaient là quand on est
sorti du restaurant et que je suis
revenu rechercher mon téléphone ils
avaient pas encore la cagou on une
fraction de second de secondes talkywie
tout ce que tu veux ils ont mis les
cagoules et ils nous sont
saation interpellation et brassard ferme
ferme ta gueule ferme ta gueule bouge
pas bouge pas tu as une arme tu as une
arme moi de manière générale je suis
très serein et calme avec la police
parce que je dis toujours que ce sont
des exécutants et mon mes ennemis ce
sont ceux qui sont dans une dynamique
néocoloniale qui sont à la tête de ces
services là donc c'est pas eux mes
ennemis à la base la DGSI elle est pas à
la tête
ou elle enquête elle enquête sur demande
de quelqu'un se lève pas comme ça ce tu
vois gratuitement un un faisceau de
présemption visiblement qui était pas
assez puisque ils ont ils ont libéré au
bout de 50 he mais ce que je veux dire
alors que les les charges qui qui t'ont
fouillé les cavités non non mais ils
l'ont fait ils étaient armés c'était
disproportionné ils tont ils t'ont oui
ils ont pris en joue bien sûr mais bien
sûr mais on joue basse on joue haute non
on joue on joue basse on joue basse j
basse ils étaient persuadés qu'on était
peut-être armé et cetera enfin j'ai
l'impression qu'ils écoutent nos
discours à moitié parce que si je
voulais faire quelque chose et lancer
une campagne armée je pourrais le faire
c'est pas mon chemin c'est pas mon
cheval de bataille c'est c'était euh de
l'arme de Po ou de l'arme semiongue arme
de point arme semi-ongue mais donc il
nous arrête il nous donne pas tout de
suite le motif je dis au nom de quoi
vous nous arrêtez et cetera je demande
vous êtes quelle police mais j'avais cru
qu'on j'ai quand même rapidement deviné
qui ils étaient mais j'avais besoin de
demander cétait la municipale
on a demandé de manière éliminatoire
qu'est-ce que c'était et puis après la
MP j'ai dit la BAC non en fait ils sont
comportés comme des des mecs de la BAC
ils se comportent comment les mecs de la
BAC comme des voyou des foischement dis
mais parce que c'est une réalité il se
comp ils se comportent je te dis toi tu
défends c'est normal tu g journaliste
français fais l'avoc donc voilà commence
pas à m'énerver c'est ce qui t'attend ne
commence pas à m'énerver non plus ça
serait dommage on a si bien commencé je
voudrais pas abîmer ta belle gueule is
je suis pas sûr c'est moi qui t'abîmer
mais bon mais bon bref euh il se
comporte quand je dis se comporte comme
des voyou c'est que il y a tu vois les
haut gradés de la police moi j'ai très
jeune on a été arrêté par la section
antiterroriste pour des bêtises parce
qu'on avait répondu aux milices
extrémistes siist que j'ai cité tout à
l'heure attends je mets un peu de nuance
et je me fais l'avocat du diable tu as
une façon de
répondre je comprends c'estd déplacement
en force et vu tes potes et vu ton
gabarit je vais te dire même les
grands-mères devaient avoir peur cher
ami on était deux ils étaient 40 même si
c tu étais sûr que tu étais deux on
était que deux B on est deux à avoir été
arrêté on était que deux je te dis la
vérité parce qu'on éétait pas venu dans
un cadre j'avais rencontré les gens et
là on était un certain nombre la veille
les opposants politiques là cet
après-midi làà on finissait de manger et
on devait chacun séparer pour aller voir
bon revient revient voilà donc des des
membres de notre entourage d'accord donc
40 on était deux je trouve que c'est
disproportionné et ils se sont comportés
la phrase le comportement moimême qui
suis non violent je leurais dit je leuri
dit le comportement là je me mets à leur
place tu es quand même sacrément taillé
et donc je me fais pas un petit sourire
comme ça tu es quand même sacrément
taillé tu es missionné par un pays je
suis missionné par personne d'autre que
Dieu toutpuissant pour mon combat et je
me bat pour mes ancêtres d'accord voilà
tu as peut-être reçu une formation
militaire et donc on vient à 40 purée
bah tu leur fais peur c'est inquiétant
quand même moi franchement
j'ai franchement je me dis ceux qui leur
ont donné les ordres c'était des mecs de
la cage au folle c'était pas sérieux
parce que parce que parce que non bah
mais c'est pas une insulte la cageau FOL
c'est un film français très français qui
représente un peu les valeurs que Macron
pr il a le droit c'est c'est c'est tout
à fait justifiable dire de tolérance de
mixité de quoi de tolérance de
de terin très
glissant sur lequel moi je glisse pas
mais mais je veux dire que pour se
comporter de cette façon c'était un
message qui cherchait à te faire passer
non moi est-ce qu'il voulait est-ce
qu'il voulait te surprendre
t'impressionner pour t'attendrir quand
ils vont ils allaient t'interroger non
non moi je te dis très clairement déjà
de un des mots volés parce qu'il y en a
qui se contrôlaient moins que d'autres
les plus jeunes qui étaient par la suite
rattrapés par leur responsable
hiérarchique euh certains m'ont dit de
toute façon euh vous allez rester un bon
bout de temps avec nous de un par
rapport à garde à vue c'est ce qui
prévoyait et il me disait que même après
c'est pas à mon avis vous sortirez pas
tout de suite donc quand quelqu'un te
dit ça céit pas une question de pression
eux ce qu'il voulaient il voulait nous
arrêter en effet brutalement
euh nous tenter de nous casser
psychologiquement problème c'est que
c'est pas notre première arrestation
et dans leur logiciel il était évident
queon allait pas sortir avant un certain
temps d'autant plus que les charges
parce qu'il faut quand même qu'on le
dise tu étais armé pas armé je suis
jamais armé tu avais un couteau sur toi
se aucune arme ma seule arme c'est mon
mon cerveau ma bouche et si tu me
manques trop de respect et mes
testicules mais bon les femmes qui n'ont
pas de testicules ont des Rin et ont un
courage aussi pour se défend ils ont des
overt voilà donc mais j'ai ce qu'il faut
pour me défendre mais comme je t'ai dit
je su une période de ma vie t cerveau
pour te défendre voilà où j'essaie de
privilégier pour moi la vérilité à un
certain âge c'est de savoir échanger et
de savoir éteindre quelqu'un
argumentativement c'est pas de sortir
les points et cetera tu vois maintenant
parfois quand on te pousse à des
extrémités je peux comprendre que tu
sors de tu as résisté à ton
interpellation à part le fait de tes 95
kout écoute on m on m'a tordu le bras
comment avec pi biche je même pas de
décrire mais en tout cas ils ils m'ont
tordu le bras et à un moment donné j'ai
dit j'ai dit qu'est-ce qui j'ai dit
qu'est-ce qui t'arrive j'ai dit
comporte-toi comportez-vous normalement
moi vous me convoquez je te donne une un
petit exemple j'ai
été la banque centrale des États
d'Afrique de l'Ouest puisque on mène une
campagne contre le France CFA et que la
banque centrale des États d'Afrique de
l'Ouest est complètement lié à ça
évidemment apporter plainte contre moi
par rapport au billet que j'avais brûlé
lors de la campagne internationale que
j'avais mené contre le néocolonialisme
et le Fran CFA tu t'es pris pour Serge
ginzebourg pas du tout bon lui c'était
un un truc de bourgeois moi c'était pour
la souveraineté de millions de gens
c'est pas la même chose c'était pour
protester contre les impôts
bon protester contre les impôts mais je
pense qu'il pense il payit pas les mêmes
impôts que enfin bref ça c'est encore un
autre sujet je va pas rentrer dessus euh
mais en tout cas on va pas comparer la
souffrance de millions de gens en
Afrique au problème que que cite Serge
ginbourg et c'était de la violence
symbolique c'est ce que je théorise dans
mon livre lAfrique Liou la mort pas je
ne veux pas la violence physique mais
m'attaquer à des symboles pour éclairer
l'esprit et dans cette bataille
culturelle très gramcienne comment il
s'appelle le livre l'Afrique libre ou la
mort c'est mon 4e livre édition Fiat
luxe qui est-ce qui touche les
droits moi je touche les droits et mon
éditeur touche les droits av vendu
combien beaucoup combien ça va pas te
dire peut-être enfin beaucoup tout est
relatif j'ai pas pas de chiffre exact
c'est mieux que je dise pas d'ailleurs
ici pour plusieurs raisons et euh c'est
beaucoup mieux on me fait un signe c'est
mieux
euh donc bref et
euh du coup tu m'as fait perdre le fil
al je le perd jamais exprès donc bref
ton interpellation donc non non donc le
voilà pour ce billet brûlé la banque
centrale des États d'Afrique de l'Ouest
a porté plainte contre moi je vivais
plus au Sénégal mais j'étais convoqué au
Sénégal mon gars j'ai payé mon billet
d'avion avec tes droits d'auteur avec
mes avec ce que j'ai réussis à récupérer
à gauche à droite pour aller me rendre
au Sénégal pour plaider ma cause alors
que j'étais accusé donc tu penses que
quelqu'un qui est capable de voyager
d'un endroit à un autre de faire des
milliers de kilomètres des centaines de
kilomèes centaines de milliers
kilomètres pour pour porter justement sa
cause va avoir peur d'une convocation
d'un DJSI j'ai été convoqué par la
section antiterroriste j'avais 24 ans
pourquoi je vais avoir peur la tgsi donc
c'était une erreur de leur part de faire
ce qu'ils ont fait et je pense qu'ils
s'en sont rendus compte à un moment
parce que lors de l'interrogatoir il
faut que je reconnaisse qu'ils ont été
très courtois très respectueux pas de
coup de botin
risque pas ça c'est une mauvaise idée et
je ne nous mentons pas non plus ils
étaient très conscients qu'ils avaient
une patate chaude dans les mains aussi
c'est-à-dire que ils savaient que à
cause de l'audience que l'on a
aujourd'hui s'il y a quelque chose qui
est fait ça allit circuler à l'extérieur
et si ça circulle à l'extérieur moi je
suis très pacifique entre guillemets il
y a des gens dans mon public qui ne le
sont pas forcément et et conscience de
ça je suis conscient je suis très
conscient du du fait que je suis un un
régulateur je suis un Inti impérialiste
fondamental maladif je crois qu'on s'en
sortira en étant enadéquation a notre
ontologie et que la la nonvolence est
une stratégie pertinente et intelligente
mais je suis conscient qu'il y a des
gens qui sont moins patients que moi il
se trouve que je suis en tête de fil de
de ce courant que je je je pense qu'il
est plus intelligent de laisser à
l'oppresseur l'arme de la violence pour
montrer son côté barbare et sauvage
c'est le message que tu fais passer à
ceux qui te suivent oui c'est le but
c'est qu'il comprennent et je l'ai dit à
plusieurs reprises il a à plusieurs
reprises il y a eu des séquences
où on a été il y avait des
manifestations il y avait des
contestations contre la présence
colonial et y a des gens qui pouvaient
s'apprêter à faire des dingueries j'ai
appelé au calme en leur disant attention
notre problème c'est le système
néocolonial c'est pas c'est pas les
c'est pas les petits gens c'est pas des
gens que j'apprécie pas forcément
fonction profondément mais qui sont des
fonctionnaires et il y a jamais eu
d'agression il faut qu'on le dise dans
le cadre de ces campagnes de
mobilisation contre le néocolonialisme
il y a jamais eu d'agression de
représentants français on s'est attaqué
symboliquement à une présence
néocoloniale c'est pas la même chose
est-ce qu'il y a eu des des bâtiments
brûlés est-ce qu'il y a eu des drapeaux
français brûlés mais est-ce que tu
penses que brûler un drapeau français ça
sert à quelque chose moi je pense que
c'est un signal qu'on envoie c'est un
signal qu'on envoiei tu me fais mal mais
bien et je le comprends et je le
comprends parfaitement mais de la même
façon que quand on pie nos ressources
quand on on aspicie nos populations
quand quand il y a une violence sociale
quand il y a le francefa et cetera ça
nous fait mal et moi mon rêve c'est
qu'on c'est qu'on arrive à un stade
attends j'arrive j'
moi mon rêve même si ça te fait mal C
ces TR couleur est-ce que tu as des
enfants non moi j'ai des enfants
combien quatre combien de femmes une
seule femme ah la dernière fois tu en
avais deux hein oui bon c'est des choses
qui arrivent et euh et mais j'ai ma
famille et je j'aime je j'aime tout le
monde dans les au sein des miens et euh
quand tu as un bébé quand tu dors la
nuit la seule façon que l'enfant Hâ de
se faire entendre nous on n'est pas les
enfants de qui que ce soit mais c'est
une parabole qui qui qui que tu vas
comprendre malgré tout quand tu vas
écouter la fin si tu fais pas de bruit
tu te fais pas entendre autre exemple
que tu vas mieux comprendre quand tu es
dans une prison tu as jamais été je
pense mais si tu es incarcéré dans une
prison hein dis ça bon je te le souhaite
pas en tout cas eu moi j'ai été j'ai
fait quelques séjours dans le casadre
toujours de long long cours toujours de
mois en isolement quel 2 mois en
isolement ouis quel établissement euh le
premier c'était fleur non boisarc 2ème
fur Mogis après c'était les cellules au
au Sénégal rebus et c'était les prisons
Burkina Faso ouais c'est clair quartier
VIP ou pas jamais euh où ça en France
non c'était en isolement c'est pas VIP
c'est là où parce qu'il y a balc il a
l'isolement mais en VIP non non non non
non non j'étais pas là où était balcani
ça c'est clair non non on était là où en
fait au départ on me mettait à des
endroits où on était en contact avec
tout le monde et dès que le directeur de
prison voyait que ça commençait à à être
checké partout
dans la promenade les gens nous
saluaient et cetera il dit lui il va
nous poser problème on met en isolement
et les deux fois en France ça s fait
comme ça reviens reviens à la DGSI donc
la
DGSI si tu me parlais de coup de bottin
après tu me parlais de quoi il dit 50 he
tu as eu à manger tu as eu à boire tu as
eu accès à un avocat ils ont essayé de
te la faire à l'envers
il menacé ils ont tout fait pour que je
ne sois pas en contact avec mon avocat
parce qu'ils arrivent pas à le joindre
pas ils m'ont dit prenez un avocat Comé
d'office je veux pas prendre l'avocat
commé d'office non je vais prendre mon
avocat il s'appelle ran Branco qui est
pas simplement un avocat et j'en profite
si tu le permets pour et je le ferai à
chaque fois que je le pourrais qui est
un frère en humanité qui a un combattant
de la justice sociale chez les Français
et c'est des gens comme lui qui me font
me rappeler ils me l'apprennent pas mais
ils me font me le rappeler qu'il existe
une possibilité de fraternité et de
solidarité entre les peuples africains
et les peup peuple en Occident c'est
très important qu'on le dise et donc
c'est un activiste d'extrême gauche
c'est une gauche souverainiste et c'est
un avocat et on on a des points de
désaccord évidemment bien sûr mais on a
aussi beaucoup de points communs en ce
qui concerne cette gauche souverainiste
antiglobaliste
euh qui est en train de petit à petit
très
progressivement montrer pointer son nez
à l'horizon il y a des points communs et
puis après il y a des différences du aux
réalités paradigmatiques de nos
populations en Afrique et en Occident
mais il y a un un un front de solidarité
et donc on je je demande à ce qu'ils
viennent au départ ils me font
intervenir un avocat commid d'office
qu'and n'arrive pas à joindre mon avocat
et je dis si c'est ça je préfère ne pas
être défendu je l'ai dit très gentiment
à l'avocat commid d'office et finalement
donc ran arrive alors que je pensais
qu'il allait même pas être capable de de
venir il arrive le lendemain et
entretemps on m'a fait comprendre que
ceux dont on m'accuse c'est-à-dire euh
atteintte aux intérêts fondamentaux de
l'État c'est une dinguerie je sais pas
si tu te rends compte quand même c'est
que quelqu'un qui n'a pas qui n'a pas de
d'armes qui n'a pas de violence qui ne
fait pas qui fait pas preuve de violence
qui a un discours strictement politique
de souveraineté mais fais pas l'ange
mais jeis pas l'ange je te parle mais
c'est un fait c'est pas l'ange et j'ai
pas envie d'être un ange je suis
kemiseba ça me suffit largement et je
suis très loin d'être un ange mais les
faits sont là
politiquement comment tu peux dire que
quelqu'un qui lutte contre le
néocolonialisme c'est quelqu'un qui qui
porte at atinte aux intérêts
fondamentaux de l'État sauf si les
intérêts fondamentaux de l'État c'est le
néocolonialisme c'est QFD et c'est
exactement ce que j'ai dit aux agents
secrets qui
m'interrogeaient qui qui lors de
l'interrogatoire me posaient ses
questions je le dis il éttaent combien
non moi j'en avais un qui m'interrogait
il y en avait un qui a interrogé mon
collègue et pant c'était toujours le
même pendant 50 he ouioui toujours le
même qui était responsable de
l'interrogatoire et éit courtois il
était sourcé il était il était courtois
j' qu'est-ce qu'il a cherché à savoir il
a cherché euh à comprendre enfin il m'a
posé la question de savoir est-ce que
vous rendez compte en gros que vos
activités portent atteinte aux intérêts
de l'État et je je aux intérêts
fondamentaux de l'État et que vous
suscitez des hostilités vis-à-vis de
l'État français j'ai dit non je dis vous
appelez quoi intérêts fondamentaux de
l'État est-ce que le Fran CFA c'est les
intérêts fondamentaux de l'État est-ce
que les bases militaires français c'est
les intérêts fondamentaux de l'État
est-ce que les multinationales qui P nos
ressources déforestation tout ce qui
s'ensuit Boloré on connaît et cetera
est-ce que c'est intérêts fondamentaux
de tat toutes ces questions c'est des
questions que j'ai posé il a retranscrit
mes questions qui faisaient qui faisaent
office de réponse mes question qui
faisait auice de réponse et je pense que
quand la juge a vu ça elle é agacé parce
que en effet c'est un contresens et
après ils me disent intelligence avec
l'ennemi dans le but de de susciter donc
des hostilités vis-à-vis de l'État je
dis mais c'est quel type d'hostilité
dont vous parlez en fait et c'est quoi
les états ennemis est-ce qu'on peut les
qualifier c'est quoi ces états ennemis
est-ce que la Russie avec lesquell vous
collaboriez bien longtemps avant que
nous on interagisse ce sont c'est un
état etnemi dans ce cas pourquoi vous ne
leur dites pas ouvertement que ce sont
vos ennemis par que on a l'impression
pas le courage de le dire est-ce que le
Venezuela Cuba la Turquie et autres
Partena le esbolla ça dû faire tiquer
quand même un peu non mais le esbolla je
vais te surprendre sur un truc tu sais
ce qu'on a appris du esbolla et tu sais
quel a été le soutien du esbolla on est
on a été à chaque fois reçu par Monsieur
Moussaoui le responsable des relations
étrangères internationales du hbollah
que des gens de l'Union européenne que
des Français eux-mêmes ont rencontré
donc je veux dire on a été assez malin
pour pas aller
voir la milice du esbollah et cetera
c'est pas eux qu'on a rencontré on a
rencontré le diplomate du esbollah qui
lui-même est invité enfin invité ils
vous ont donné de l'argent le esbola non
mais j'ai dit parce que je suis très on
sait êre stratège quand il le faut j'ai
dit publiquement je crois que c'était à
TF1 l'émission de Yan Barz je crois TF1
plus ou je sais plus trop quoi j'ai dit
on a reçu plus on a reçu du hzbolla plus
de soutien que d'autres tu sais ce qui
nous a appris le hzbolla lors de nos
déplacements là-bas et nos invitations
là-bas comment organiser des programmes
sociaux de haute portée qui permettront
de toucher la population mais tu sais
pourquoi vas-y je t'écoute parce après
tu peux recruter écoute une chose est
certaine on est des populations
extrêmement précarisé en Afrique donc il
y a une injustice il y a il y a une
injustice sociale non mais mais tous les
gens qu'on aideent c'est pas des gens
qu'on recrute c'est ça c'est une version
très
mercantile c'est une version très
mercantile de la justice sociale c'est
pas notre il y a pas de souci non mais
je je le comprends il y a pas de souci
tu fais ton rôle je fais le mien et je
te dis que on a été
bouleversé parce qu'on a appris parce
qu'on a vu par les informations et par
les formations qu'on a eu sur ces
questions on a visité un un certain
nombre d'institutions d'hôpitaux de
structures qui qui organisent du soutien
scolaire des distribution de repas et
cetera dans la communauté euh
euh qui est sensible justement aux
activités du esbolla et c'est grâce à ça
on va se dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont comme je le fais tout le temps de
toute façon qu'on a mis en place le
programme alodo qui est un programme
d'entraide et de solidarité àodo en
fondb ça signifie solidarité entraide et
c'est notre axe politico-économique
l'entraide le solidarisme d'accord euh
pour venir en aide à nos populations on
a mis en place des microcrédits euh sans
intérêt
qu'on a donné à des mères en état
d'extrême précarité des maères de
famille qui une fois qu'elles avaient pu
monter leurs entreprises de rembourser
le microcrédit et c'était redistribué à
d'autres entités mieux que les hommes
d'ailleurs mais clairement mais
c'esténéralité donc bon bref quand elles
entreprennent elles font ça de manière
plus sérieuse en réalité tu sais
pourquoi dis-moi ta perception je te
DIRIS la mien elles porent sur leur dos
leur fardeau elles portent sur leur
ventre leur motivation c'est c'est c'est
bien dit et parfois ell portent dans
leur ventre aussi le le le leur futur et
le futur de de l'humanité aussi et c'est
pour ça qu'on dit qu'on quand on dit en
Afrique que la la femme africaine est la
matrice de l'humanité ça veut dire ce
que ça veut dire bref je ferme et la
femme de manière générale Lucy elle
s'appelait non ça c'est ce qu'ils disent
je suis pas sûr que Luce soit là ça
c'est encore autre chose reviens reviens
à à tes petites 50 heur donc pees heur
qu'on a cru qu' allait se transformer
parce qu'ils nous disent vous risquez 10
ans pour ça et vous risquez 30 ans pour
ça 10 ans c'était pour quoi c'est 10 an
c'était pour euh
euh à non disons c'était pour hostilité
se met de
l'hostilité à la France en Afrique dans
les territoires d'autres m et 30 ans
s'est porté atteinte aux intérêts fond
fondamentaux et pas collision avec
l'ennemi et et en collusion avec
l'ennemi des États-Unis puiss étrangère
puissance étrangère ennemi et cetera de
est-ce qu'ils ont dit ennemi ils l'ont
dit dans l'interrogatoire ouis ils l'ont
dit dans l'interrogatoire ils ont dit
mais ça n dérange pas de cétait quelle
puissance qu'ils ont nommé ils ont nommé
tout ils ont parlé de de Russie d'Iran
Venezuela et cetera j'ai dit mais donc
vous avez desclat donc Azerbaïdjan non
parce que l'Azerbaïdjan on les avait pas
encore rencontré à ce moment-là tu les
as rencontré quand depuis que je suis
plus français c'est c'est quand depuis
quelques mois maintenant
et l'azerbaan et pareil je veux dire
tous ces pays-là qu'on vient de citer
j'ai dit à l'inspecteur des services
secrets la déjà ici j'ai dit mais il
s'appelait Harry
j'ai dit mais donc vous donc Macron a
déclaré la guerre à ces pays j'ai
peut-être j'ai j'ai loupé les infos sur
Google actu peut-être j'étais pas au
courant je dis il a déclaré que ces pays
étai des pays ennemis et il a souris en
disant il ne répond pas sur ça non mais
s'il y a une déclaration de guerre faut
qu'on soit tous au courant mais s'il y a
pas de déclaration de guerre que des
états nous soutiennent dans des
programmes d'activité social ù nous
soutiennent dans des déplacements et
cetera pour qu'on mène nos activités
notre agenda contre le néocolonialisme
là il donne un sandwich non non il nous
donner une barquette gluante de pates
est-ce que tu as m est-ce que tu as pu
prier pendant ta garde à vue je prie
tout le temps ch non mais est-ce que tu
as pu prier pendant que ta garde V je
prie je répète c'est ma réponse je prie
tout le temps donc à un moment donné je
sais qu'il y avais un des gardiens de
prison qui me
voyaent qui devait me prendre pour un
malade parce que j'invoqué Dieu
vraimentis pourquoi quel Dieu t invoqué
le seul qui existe il y a un seul Dieu
il y a 10000 appellations il a un seul
créateur René
g prophète c'est ça ah bon non je te
pose la question tu crois en quoi est-ce
que tu je crois en Dieu tout-puissant je
suis ce qu'on appelle un
traditionnaliste un traditionniste ou un
un pérénialiste tu connais René Genon tu
peux ok la crise du monde moderne je
t'encourage profondément à le
lire je crois qu'il existe une tradition
primordiale qui a à la base de toutes
les religions religion c'est religiaré
ça signifie relier la Tradition
Primordiale c'est le message originel
qui a été la matrice de tout et qui a
permis à l'humanité d'être guidée et on
retrouve des traces de cette tradition
primordiale partout dans le monde si
j'avais pas la politique j'aurais été ce
qu'on appelle un archéologue
métaphysique c'est-à-dire que j'aurais
été à la recherche de ces traces de
cette tradition primordiale partout dans
le monde mais je l'étudie dans son
acception africaine à travers les
manifestations continentale africaine
mais aussi parfois diasporique comme à
Cuba ou à Venezuela où je vois ce que ce
que autres pratiqu et je crois pour te
répondre en conclusion sur cette
question je crois qu'il n'y a de dieu
que Dieu clair t sandwich il était V on
passe de Dieu au sandwich tuaimes pas
trop Dieu toi mais ton sandwich il était
végétarien jambon ou crudité donc euh
jambon crudité ou poulet donc je termine
en disant t'ont proposer un choix de
sandwich tu peux être relou quand tu
veux euh il n'y a de dieu que Dieu et je
me bats dans une démarche de rectitude
en tout cas j'essaie de l'être je suis
loin d'être parfait et j'essaie
constamment d'honorer mes ancêtres
méritants voilà le combat qui est le MEN
P et merci infiniment à eux et ils
vivent en nous comme le disait Steve
bico il vivent en nous tout le temps
père de la black consciousness du
mouvement Black consciousness en Afrique
du Sud donc pour ce qui est les sandwich
on a pas de sandwich on avait des pâtes
gluantes avec ou sans
lardon je sais pas ce qu'il y avait de
toute façon je les mangeais pas donc
voilà
et c'était objectivement de toutes les
Dét que j'ai faite c'est la première
fois j'étais en train de me dire [__]
qui nous met rapidement en dépôt dans
une cellule normale parce que là au 4è
sous-sol de la DGSI là où il mettent les
terroristes et cetera j'ai connu pire au
Sénégal très clairement mais c'était pas
agréable là on était objectivement au 4è
sous-sol il fais faisit archi froid on
passe d'un endroit de on vit en Afrique
donc avis tes chaussures j'avais des
chaussettes d'Afrique très fes
euh on a pas le aux chaussures on
t'enlève les chaussures à les lassé et
cetera
euh une sorte de linceul pour couverture
annonciateur peut-être de ce qu'il nous
souhaite psychologiquement c'est une
façon de parler non dit ça va mais bon
c'est une préparation psychologique il y
a pas de larmoement on s'est adapté on n
pas pleurer il y a aucun souci sur ça on
a connu bien pire que ça mais c'était
pas agréable et après on moi je dormais
environ 3h par nuit 3 4h après le
lendemain on a interrogé et puis voilà
toute la journée
sur sur les raisons de notre combat sur
nos liens avec tel il nous montre des
photos que des sources ouvertes c'estàd
que là aussi ça pose quand même question
c'est dire que moi j'ai grandi en disant
les services secrets c'est ils enquêtent
ils te suivent partout et cetera ils
suivent il y a des endroits où j'ai vu
qu'il nous suivaient c'est une tuas vu
comment bah il y a des photos C qui
prenait des coups de soleil non mais il
y a des photos qu'ils ont pris ils ont
pu que nous suivre parce qu'il y a des
trucs c'était pas trouvable certains sur
internet il y avait Filat des filatures
il y avait des filatures mais c'était
pas la majorité du dossier les 3/4 du
dossier tuas pas vu tout ce qu'ils
avaient j'ai vu ce qu'il m'ont montré et
de ce qu'il m'ont montré
90 % c'est des sources 80 % c'est les
sources ouvertes tu vois et et même les
sources même les sources d à des
filatures et cetera vous les enquêtes et
cetera parce qu'on est on est on est
suivi il s'en cache pas par les services
secrets mais même même ces source là ne
corrobore en aucun cas leurs accusations
c'est-à-dire que dire qu'on voyage en
Amérique du Sud au Venezuela OK et donc
dire qu'on voyage en Turquie dire qu'on
voyage en Iran dire qu'on voyage en
Russie la question c'est pas le voyage
la merde quand même non non on cherche
et je reprends mand là on cherche à
avoir les possibilités d'être le plus
efficients dans notre résistance et dans
notre résistance on est obligé de faire
preuve d'alliance estce est-ce que tu as
été faire des alliances avec les
mouvement noir américain c'est par là
qu'on a commencé et on est encore
aujourd'hui extrêmement lié à un certain
nombre de mouvements afro-américains
moi j'étais formé à Nation of Islam donc
au groupe d'études j'ai commencé je
passe un bonjour à à celui qui se
faisait appeler auparavant Tony Mohammed
qui était le ministre de faracan la
mosquée numéro 27 à Los Angeles qui nous
suit beaucoup aujourd'hui et qui est
très ému de voir quelqu'un qui l'a vu
très jeune
euh de court à de court instant devenir
aujourd'hui ce que je suis et après j'ai
été formé entre guillemets un temps un
temps en France et par la suite au
Canada je passe un gros bonjour à mirael
Youssouf Mohammed qui est mon grand
frère que je porte en estime donc je
suis très lié au mouvement
afro-américain je suis très lié tu pens
de Black Liv matters pour moi black live
matters fait partie d'une
instrumentalisation néolibérale sur le
terrain sociétal de la cause noire on
est passé de Black Power à Black live
matters en gros on est passé de
prenons-nous en charge ah e les mecs la
vie des Noirs contte pour moi c'est de
la victimisation ce n'est pas
l'autodétermination et c'est si je
devais prendre un parallèle c'est un
petit peu comme la question euh
tu vois par exemple les féè pour moi
c'est une instrumentalisation
néolibérale d'une question rationnelle
et sincère que l'on doit se pososer sur
la sur les droits des femmes et sur le
le rôle et la situation des femmes mais
les féè c'est une instrumentalisation
pour un but qui n'est pas la libération
des femmes mais la libéralisation des
femmes c'est pas pareil Michel klouscar
dans le libéralisme libertaire
conceptualiser le cette
instrumentalisation de cause nobles pour
des objectifs qui étaient profondément
ancré dans cette dynamique du
capitalisme qui étit très important et
on le voit black live matters les les
les fondatrices entre guillemets ou les
cofondatrices oné c'est un slogan à la
base qui est devenu viral et après ils
ont décidé d'en faire un mouvement par
la suite Soros et toutes les
institutions globalistes financent les
organisations et on a vu après pas queul
qui les finance il y a peut-être des
gens normaux des choses comme ça- Black
ça c'est pas si tu veux que je te fasse
un exposé sur je peux faire que tu leur
reproches peuvent te reprocher la même
chose en disant que tu es inst
instrumentalisé par la fussille et le
marteau ou instrumentalisé tu sais
pourquoi tu peux pas faire ça parce que
nous ce combat là on l'a commencé à une
époque où Poutine n'était pas en poste
on l'a commencé à une époque où l'Iran
ne se souvenait même plus de où était
peut-être le sel on l'a commencé à une
période où tous les gens que tu viens de
citer se préoccuper pas de nous c'est un
fait juste pour finir j'ai une chance
c'est que j'ai commencé à être médiatisé
très tôt en OC en France à 24 ans
diabolisé hystériquement mais tout le
monde sait que j'ai commencé mon mon
combat pour la défense du droit de mon
peuple manière peut-être plus offensive
et plus radicale dans la forme dans le
fond je pense qu'il y a un substrat
commun clairement mais j'ai commencé
très tôt donc tout le monde sait que
j'ai combattu à une époque où ces
gens-là que tu viens de citer n'étaient
pas liés au aux réalités géopolitiques
africaines c'est important quand même
qu'on puisse le dire donc maintenant je
reviens à la garde à vue
euh donc ils m'ont posé des questions
sur sur la Russie sur Wagner ils m'ont
posé des questions sur le esbollah
majoritairement sur Wagner et la Russie
aussi sur le
hbollah ça se consistait en quoi c'est
alors on t'a vu Prigogine estce oui quel
était vos lien Prigogine est-ce que vous
connaissez une telle telle telle tel
est-ce que vous étiez vous avez été payé
par Wagner je dis mais écoutez przine
était à la tête d'un empire il avait
10000 structures dont Wagner il avait
10000 autres structures moi moi j'ai
jamais rencré tu as fait deschecs est-ce
que c'est 10000 structures t'ont fait
des chèqus jamais ils t'ont posé ça
comme question ils m'ont posé ces
questions mais jamais je prends pas de
chèque de toute façon donc comme ça
l'histoire elle est réglée tu prends
quoi des
cadeaux moi ce que je veux c'est la
libération de mon peuple et comme dirait
l'autre la Moula j'aai la chercher là où
elle est voilà j' la chercher là où elle
est pour pousser les miens à se libérer
c'est très clair et je sais que si
j'avais pris cette Moula de George
choros j'aurais été peut-être j'aurais
le prix Nobel aujourd'hui parce que
l'audience que on a ils auraient dit
c'est voilà un nouvel architecte du
développement mais j'ai choisi le côté
obscur de la Force j'ai été non il faut
pas dire que tu as chois obsc de la
force obscur chez moi c'est pas négatif
je suis je suis noir et fier de l'être
et je suis obscur pour certains et fier
de l'être mais bon revenons à ton
interrogatoire on est dedans on y est
dedans dans C pose des questions sur
Pierre Paul jaacques d'où ça vient les
sous Pierre Paul jacov et donc et
qu'est-ce que tu réponds je leur répond
ce que je te réponds là on est une
organisation africaine 50 50 he je leur
réponds qu'on est non déjà je bon je je
leur réponds que notre on est une
organisation africaine et que de on n
pas de compte à rendre à qui que ce soit
en ce qui concerne notre activité tu
avais encore ta nationalité française à
l'époque au moment de l'arrestation non
non non je suis venu avec le passeport
diplomatique on reparlera ta d'échéance
de nationalité ok qui a était la
prémisse à ça he parce que c'est la même
procédure he les accusations qu'on nous
donne pour la déjà ici là c'est pour ces
mêmes motifs qu'on a eu qu'on m'a retiré
la nationalité alors est-ce qu'ils
avaient fait des écoutes est-ce qu'ils
avaient quelque chose de concret est-ce
qu'il pas d'écoutes source ouvertes des
écoutes si on s'est fait arrêter par des
écoutes donc il y a des écoutes mais
source ouvertees donc sur les réseaux
sociaux on a une particularité c'est que
comme moi je n'ai rien à cacher et que
j'estime que le combat que je mène c'est
un combat juste mais je montre en tout
cas une grande partie de ce qu'on doit
montrer donc quand je me déplace ce qui
te reproche et les procédures 10 et 30
ans bah tu te fais pas arrêter s'ils ont
pas un minimum de biscuit benah bah
visiblement ils en avaient pas
visiblement ils en avaient pas leur seul
problème réel et je le comprends et on
le voit aujourd'hui aux Antilles on le
voit aujourd'hui en Afrique francophone
il y a une contestation qui est réelle
ils savent que j'ai été un catalyseur à
bon nombre d'endroits et que nous sommes
plus que jamais encore
aujourd'hui une entité qui réussit à en
travaillant avec les organisations
locales à on réussi à mutualiser nos
forces et à densifier la question de la
contestation vis-à-vis de l'injustice
sociale la colonialité de tout ce qui
tout ce qu'il en tout tout ce qui touche
à cette à cette thématique là et donc
forcément ils ont décidé de nous cibler
comme étant j'ai ça m'a fait rire la
formule comme je dis tête de fil du
panafricanisme international francophobe
ils m'ont appris tu es francophobe je
suis absolument pas francophobe
j'ai tu sais ça me fatigue même d'avoir
à m'expliquer sur ça je le fais parce
qu'on est là en une interview de longue
durée
mais est-ce que parce que tu dénonces
Macron ça veut dire que tu es contre la
France est-ce que parce que je dénonce
la corruption
endémique de certains dirigeants
africains ça veut dire que je suis
contre l'Afrique c'est stupide est-ce
que parce que je m'oppose à Patrice
Talon ça veut dire que je suis contre
mon pays c'est stupide je m'attaque à
une politique néocoloniale je m'attaque
pas à la France j'ai j'ai grandi en
France certes j'ai vécu beaucoup la
négrophobie aussi quand j'étais jeune
euh mais j'ai connu aussi des gens
extraordinaires en France j'ai connu des
gens avec qui j'ai noué des amitiés
réels en France j'ai une partie de ma
vie j'ai quitté la France à 28 ans à
Strasbourg je suis à Strasbourg j'ai
vécu la les 14 premières années de ma
vie dans les petits patelins on était
les seuls noirs des des kilomètres et
des kilomètres à la ronde avis la coupe
de Dragon Ball j'avais la coupe à sang
Goku j'ai de sang Goku si tu veux tu tu
veux me faire un cours de français il y
a pas de problème et et j'ai je suis
arrivé en région Paris B parisienne à 14
ans j'ai vécu de mes 14 ans jusqu'à mes
28 ans en bangliu parisienne tuas encore
un peu l'accent strasbourgeois
d'ailleurs bah surtout que j'ai pas vécu
j'aurais du mal à avoir l'accent tu me
confonds avec Abdel
Malik je sais pas si je le prends comme
un compliment bref mais
euh mais bref bon slameur so dit en
passant et voilà et qui a le droit
d'avoir ses pensées je taquine quand je
dis ça c'est un frère et je suis
solidaire de tous mes frères même si on
peut ne pas avoir du tout les mêmes
opinions
et donc je je n'ai rien mon mon problème
n'est pas la France mon problème c'est
la France-Afrique mon problème c'est le
concubinage incestueux tu mas dit d'une
oligarchie néolibérale française avec
une oligarchie putrifiée africaine qui
ne pense pas à l'avenir juste pour
terminer c'est très important qui ne
pense pas à la non non je l'ai pas dit
dire quand tu tu es sorti du sousol
ouais je comprends bien je l'ai pas dit
comme je te dis là tout seul dans ta
cellule où il y avait gr tu veux pas
qu'on finisse
not je veux dire qu'on a une on a une
élite
africaine qui est la plus grande
responsable de ce qui nous arrive et
c'est pour ça que quand on parle
d'urgence panafricanist tu sais en
Afrique dans les mouvements citoyens il
y a trois types de mouvements je fais
une cartographie rapide il y a les
mouvements citoyens qui ont pour
spécificité la lutte pour la démocratie
la lutte contre les dictatures et cetera
mais qui ne prennent selon moi qu'une
facette du problème parce que si tu
luttes contre la dictature le dictateur
mais tu luttes pas contre le système qui
soutend la dictature tu changes un
dictateur par un autre on l'a vu auss
Sénégal abdouah est parti il a été
remplacé par Macky Sall qui était qui a
été porté par le peuple et Macky s'est
retrouvé comme étantté plus dangereux
même que que que que abdouah wad donc le
problème pour toi c'est un dictateur pas
pour moi pour la population sénégalaise
qu' l' a considéré comme tel une grande
partie en tout cas et et donc on est
dans une démarche où on lutte il y a des
gens qui luttent pour la démocratie il y
a d'autres qui lutte contre la
colonisation d'accord spécifiquement
contre ça et nous urgence panafricaniste
on est et je pense que c'est les raisons
aussi de notre succès en Afrique
francophone et dans les Territoires
d'outrer on est une structure hybride
sur ce terrainlà on lutte à la fois
contre la malgouvernance parce que c'est
une réalité endémique dans nos pays dans
No sociétés colonisé et néocolonisé et
on lutte contre le système néocolonial
parce que ce sont ces deux facettes
d'une même pièce qui cromist qui
conseille pour faire une proposition
politique autour de ça bien sûr on
travaille beaucoup avec un certain
nombre d'économistes j'ai une grosse
pensée pour des gens comme Mamadou
Koulibali qui est un géant de l'économie
le premier agrégé en économie ivoirien
l' ancien président de l'Assemblée
Nationale de Côte d'Ivoire qui est un
génie avec un C ou un K avec un K qui
est un génie dans son domaine et qui qui
est que j'ai connu par le biais d'un de
d'amis que dont je suis proche qui fait
un travail extraordinaire et celui moi
qui m'a le premier touché sur la
question économique en ce qui concerne
justement la souveraineté africaine
c'est chchang Puemi qui euh a été le
premier à parler de la question du CFA
d'accord c'est aux alentours de ma
première peine de prison que j'ai pu euh
euh me questionner sur justement euh ces
travaux sur l'injustice caractérisée qui
était le Fran CFA si tu veux on fera un
exposé tout à l'heure après si tu Me'
laisses la possibilité et qui euh parce
que aujourd'hui plus que jamais adossé à
l'euro est adossé à à une monnaie
beaucoup trop forte pour nos économie
locale et cela anéantit le processus de
compétitivité de nos pays ça facilite
les les transactions
les interactions et la démarche des
entreprises européennes et françaises
mais ça discrimine profondément les
entreprises africaines et nos nations
africaines sur ces questions donc oui on
a des on a des économistes il y a lui a
des gens comme nicolasbou qui font
travail aussi qui passz à mon sens
soutenu par la population mais il y a
des gens il y a des grands qui font un
gros travail revenons revenons à au 4è
sous-sol où il faisit froid tu vas finir
par y aller à force de l'invoquer comme
ça de quoi la 4 sous soussol de la DGSI
je sais pas pourquoi il m'emmèner là-bas
mais ils ont plus ils ont plus de risque
qu'utre chose aveci en tout cas question
quand toi tu étais tu étais tout seul
dans ta cellule ou j'éis seul dans ma
cellule oui j'étais seul dans ma cellule
seuléta seul il y pas de place pour
d'autres est-ce que c'était des
toilettes pr il y avait non il y avait
les toilettes et c'était
propre qu'est-ce qu'on appelle propre il
y avait pas de frontière entre les
toilettes et là où tu manges si tu veux
ça donc ça veut dire que si tu si tu
défquais pour parler un langage fleuri
bah et que tu mangeais dans le M dans le
même temps just e après tu avais l'odeur
de c'était turque ou c'était non c'était
à la française frçiseise bon il y avait
du papier on a dû demander du papier on
a dû demander du papier question ils
t'ont lâché ensuite comme ça ils t'ont
sorti de tes ton 4è
sous-sol salut comment ça s'est
passé la garde à vue de la deuxè ou la
3è journée je sais même plus 3è journée
la 3è journée fini et donc ils disent à
à Ran Bronco
à moi-même que à mon avocat à moi-même
que rendez-vous demain à 14h parce
qu'ils ont d'autres ils avaient d'autres
TR dossier à gérer le matin et donc on
allait continuer la garde à vue et il
était ils étaient persuadés que on
allait se voir le lendemain et même le
policier qui nous interrogait disait
monsieur SBA de toute façon il va
falloir faire preuve d'endurance parce
que ça va durer tu vois donc il était
persuadé de son truc et est-ce qu'il t'a
annoncé une garde à vue pour 96 he il aa
pas annoncé mais il a dit qu'on y avait
de fortes chances que ça aille jusque-
là il a dit qu'il y avait de fortes
chances que ça aille jusque là et que vu
les charges de toute façon qui
était présente face à nous contre nous
ça ne pouvait normalement pas en être
autrement et je pense ce qui s'est passé
quand on analyse à postériori il y a eu
deux facteurs le premier facteur c'est
que je pense qu'ils sont rendu compte ou
un autre ministère ou peut-être de
manière beaucoup plus verticale euh
leurs supérieurs ont fait comprendre ou
un corps étranger qui fait partie des
autorités leur a fait comprendre que ce
que vous êtes en train de faire là vous
êtes en train de faire exactement ce que
Kemy Seba veut et c'est la réalité parce
que nous notre stratégie c'est la
stratégie du judoka ou de Mohamed Ali
contre Forman plus tu nous tu nous
attaques tu dépenses de l'énergie contre
nous plus tu nous persécutes plus tu
fais monter notre message en terme
d'audience vis-à-vis de notre population
l'audience qu'on a aujourd'hui elle est
due à 50 % à notre travail d'ingénierie
sociale et et de propagation du message
politique et l'autre partie c'est les
persécutions qu'on subit c'est parce que
plus on a attaqué les gens il se disent
mais comment ça se fait que ces mecs-là
sont attaqués ces hommes là et ces
femmesl sont attaquées s'ils sont
attaqués c'est qu'ils disent la vérité
on a on on est venu te chercher
gentiment tu as posé quel question
gentim gentiment ou0 comme tu parles pas
vite on a été obligé de prendre 50 heû
ou bien sûr on on va dire ça comme ça
fallait qu'on pose des questions on va
dire ça comme ça mais pour pour pour
éclaircir les zones d' en tout cas sauf
que eux comment s'était positionné il me
disaient que il me faisait comprendre
qu'après la garde à vue vu les charges
qui sont retenues contre nous ça il
allait avoir un minimal mandat de dépôt
un mandat de dépôt avec un passeport
diplomatique c'est envisageable ça
mandat de dépôt faut bien comprendre
passeport diplomatique j'avais un ordre
de mission en Espagne j'avais fait mes
rendez-vous et mes réunions en Espagne
pour la France j'étais pas j'avais pas
le statut diplomatique le statut
diplomate excuse-moi pour la France ou
pour les autres endroits où je suis allé
j'y vais parce que j'ai un visa et donc
je suis en règle en tant que tel et
évidemment quand un passeport
diplomatique quoi qu'on en dise ne nous
montons pas tu as plus d'avantage dans
certaines séquences que d'autres c'est
une réalité papier toilette en 2 minutes
comment tuas le papier toilette en 2
minutes bon il y a des choses quand même
qui vont plus vite et même dans les
aéroports ça va beaucoup plus vite et
que il y a beaucoup beaucoup de choses
quand tu es arrêté quand tu présente ton
passeport diplomatique sauf si c'est a
déjà ici généralement c'est beaucoup
plus fluide c'est une réalité c'est pour
ça que je suis très content d'avoir ce
passeport diplomatique nigérien et je
remercie les autorités pour cela et donc
ils t'ont sortis TR r d' notamment ils
t'ont mis dans l'ascensure ils t'ont dit
maintenant c'est bon comment ça s passé
donc et donc il y a un un ha gradé je
l'ai vu par rapport à la manière dans
les autres se sont limite courbés quand
il est arrivé dans la cellule les les
matons
euh il vient et il me dit de manière
très énervée c'est là où j'ai compris
que c'était pas quelque chose qui
souhaitait tu as interprété comme énervé
il Ava peut-être mal dormi non non non
je vais te dire pourquoi parce que c'est
la manière dont il a répondu avec moi
dont il m'a répondu qui m'a fait
comprendre que c'était pas ce qu'il
voulait essayer de recoller ça avec le
propos de l'officier de la DGSI qui nous
interrogait qui nous avait dit que le
lendemain de toute façon ça allait durer
longtemps et que vu commence à se
profiler selon lui il y avait de fortes
chances que ça puisse aller beaucoup
plus loin je ferme la parenthèse euh il
vient il me dit euh pouvezv signer ce
document s'il vous plaît et je dis avant
de signer j'aimerais bien savoir ce qu
le document et il dit vous êtes libéré
je dis ah je suis libéré et je dis ah
vous allez me vous allez me renvoyer
chez chez l'ami de Macron Patrice Talon
je dis il y a pas de problème de toute
façon on finira par se retrouver d'une
façon ou d'une autre c'estàd c'était des
menaces que moi je lançais moi je lance
pas de menace moi mais je dis les choses
je dis on finira par se retrouver je dis
je parle de talon Patrice Talon je parle
pas de l'officier de police et on va se
retrouver puisque de toute façon tard
talon partira et une nouvelle génération
prendra ses responsabilités au Bénin
donc il me dit je vous dis que vous êtes
libéré vous êtes libéré vous êtes libre
vous signez vous partez et il m'a parlé
je dis en gr je mais vous avez pas
besoin de vous énerver monsieur et il me
regarde en sec courant la tête et cetera
et dit accompagnez-le pour j'ai senti
que c'est c'est pas quelque chose qu'
avait décidé de lui-même mais c'est
quelque chose qui qui était tombé sur
l'équipe qui enquêtait sur cette sur ce
ce dossier là c'est pas quelque chose
qu'il souhaitait et sinon il m'aurait
pas il nous aurait pas laissé autant de
faisaux d'indice à moi et à mon collègue
pour nous dire que ça va durer longtemps
vu comment c'est parti de toute façon
quand vous on on vous laisse des des
peines de 10 ans ou de 30 ans c'est
c'est mandat de dépôt minimum il av ils
avaient peut-être des gros biscuits ils
pensaient qu'ils avaient mais leur
dossier é leur dossier objectivement je
te le dis il est vide parce que c'est
c'est ce n'est que source à
interprétation et une fois que tu
rappelles que ce qu'ils appellent
intérêts fondamentaux nous on appelle ça
néocolonialisme que France FAA base
militaire et cetera et cetera pour eux
eux ils qualifient ça de fondamental
intérêt fondamental de l'État moi
j'estime que ça c'est pas des intérêts
fondamentaux pour la population
française c'est des intérêts
fondamentaux pour une oligarchie qui se
gave à la tête de l'État mais pas pour
le peuple français qui trime donc c'est
pas les intérêts fondamentaux de l'État
c'est les intérêts d'une caste apatriite
financière qui se fait de l'argent sur
le dos de son peuple et d'un autre
question question l'uranium oui c'est
important pour la France c'est très
important pour la France et c'est pour
ça que les autorités du nigère on une
démarche extraordinaire à un moment
donné de de rompre les contrats et de
rompre les démarches avec avec Orano C à
ton initiative non non faut qu'on est-ce
que tu as participé à mettre le le
là-dessus là nous nous sur à quoi on
participe c'est à éveiller les
consciences sur les questions de
souveraineté par ça les les agents de la
DGSI l'uranium le Niger ainsi de su
m'ont parlé de mon rôle dans les dans
les contestations et dans les
revendications au Niger puisqu'ils
savent que je veux dire on milite au
Niger au burcula au Mani au au Burkina
Faso au Mali au Bénin et dans toute
l'Afrique de l'Ouest depuis 2015 2016 tu
vois on a commencé nos manifestations à
ce moment-là et avant ça c'était la
télévision donc ils savent notre
responsabilité dedans maintenant les
décisions sont prises de manière
souveraine par les dirigeants des états
de
l'alliance du Sahel d'accord de la es et
il y a une démarche d'autodétermination
forcené de ces pays qui ont compris que
ils devaient compter sur leur propres
forces et avancer en comptant sur
eux-mêmes en priorité nous notre rôle
c'est un rôle de qui qui consiste en
terme en tant que idéologue
panafricaniste quelque part à éveiller
les consciences et à orienter la
population dans une direction de
l'autodétermination quelque part si tu
reviens en France tu penses que tu vas
te faire accueillir à
l'aéroport écoute déjà de un je ne passe
pas par l'aéroport
et de
deux je
suis pas forcément
enclin à revenir en
France ton saisi ton téléphone ta
tablette ta monde connecté ils ont saisi
du mat ils ont saisi du matériel sur
lequel ils trouveront pas de secret
politique c'était chiffré ton matériel
ou pas je suis pas rentré dans ces
détails oui sans doute oui chiffré
est-ce que toi tu chiffres tes données
est-ce que tu j'ai pas donné ces éléms
là même si je t'apprécie je vaux pas les
donner je va pas les donner mais mais
une chose qui est certaine c'est que ce
qu'ils ont trouvé trouveront rien
politiquement dedans il ils t'ont
demandé ton mot de passe ilsont ilsont
demandé je l'ai refusé j'ai refusé de le
donner ce qu'ils veulent faire il feront
ce qu'ils ont à faire tu vois est-ce que
tu as envie de parler par exemple du
business en Afrique et des entreprises
occidentales qui se positionnent pour
faire du business avec l'Afrique est-ce
qu'il y a une francophobie est-ce que
les Français sont cramés là-bas est-ce
que les Français vont subir ou subissent
du racisme est-ce que les Français on on
porte peut-être les erreurs de nous dir
g passé est-ce que il y a de la
francophobie instrumentalisée organisée
en Afrique déjà pour commencer il y a il
y a je connais pas de cas
de de cannibalisme
anti-français en Afrique on aime la
nourriture pimentée et le français et le
Fran et le français n'est pas oh vous ne
dis pas le nous aussi toi peut-êtreimes
la nourriture pimentée mais je sais pas
si tous les Français aiment ça mais euh
et le le le le français en tant
qu'individu n'est pas pimenté pour qu'on
cherche à le manger à le cuire à petit
feu on n'est pas des cannibales ça je te
je je te rassure non c'est pas comme
dans Tintin ou comme le croi les
autorités françaises maintenant il y a
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs afrodescendant
de nationalité française qui viennent
faire du commerce en afque d'accord mais
est-ce que-ce que BES noir pour aller
faire du business si tu me permets de la
de me laisser la souveraineté de ma
réponse je vais te donner la réponse qui
qui qui convient en te disant que qui me
convient en tout cas et j'espère qu'elle
te conviendra il y a beaucoup il y a
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs
afrodescendants qui viennent faire du
business il y a aussi des entrepreneurs
qui ne sont pas afrodescendants qui sont
Français de souche ou de branche ou
portug il y en a qui viennent de Racine
et tant et tant qu'il viennent tant
qu'il viennent dans un cadre de respect
dans certaines zones ils peuvent le
faire c'est quoi certaines zones bah il
y a certains endroits où ça sera plus
facile de faire du commerce parce que
dans d'autres il y a d'autres où c'est
aujourd'hui quand tu es entrepreneur
français c'est plus difficile pourquoi
mais parce queon a été trop pillé et il
y a des gens qui non moi je suis pas
responsable si je veux faire du business
mais j'ai dit on j'ai pas dit que tu
nous as payé j'ai dit nos pays ont été
trop piillés ils n'ont pas été tropillés
par le français du quotidien mais nos
pays ont été pillés par une élite qui
vous pie aussi vous autres France
périphérique et tout ce qui s'en suit
d'accord mais qui du du coup a entraîné
une méfiance pour ne pas dire parfois
une défiance chez certains euh de de
membres de nos populations et c'est
quelque chose je prends l'exemple un
exemple très simple on va partir dans
autre chose mais il il y a tellement de
choses qui ont été effectuées en ce qui
concerne nos
populations en terme de de de de de
démarche de de pillage je pense à Boloré
je pense à à Bernard Henri levville
preuv pour B bouloré tu é preuv pour
Bernard L ou quoi la déforestation il a
été accusé judiciairement il y a il y a
eu des procès pour ça Boré il y a eu des
procès innombrables pour ça là va
chercher tes fat checkers il vont ils
vont te le dire c'est c'est ça dépasse
l'entendement et quand on parle
justement de changement climatique mais
occuponsnous quand on dit on en a parlé
ça avec les gilets jaunes constituant
justement parce que ce sont des
préoccupations pour tout le monde si on
veut justement régler les problèmes du
changement climatique et des
catastrophes climatiques qui vont en
courir par rapport à ça des catastrophes
humaines bah il faut déjà prendre soin
de la forêt il faut éviter la
déforestation et donc donc quand on
lutte contre le capitalisme contre le
néolibéralisme c'est relié justement à
cette démarche de protection de
l'environnement et de régulation
justement de de de la problématique
climatique en tant que tel c'est
important qu'on le dise
donc sans compter après maintenant les
campagnes on va dans autre chose mais
les campagnes de vaccination j'ai encore
en tête le scandale de de Pfizer au
Nigéria où ils toujours en prenant la
chair noire comme des cobailles c'est
c'est sourcé ça c'est archi sourcé tu te
Pfizer mais partout partout les même
l'OMS on a parlé c'est des rapport de
l'OMS qui en parle et tu tapes C
justement ce ce cette grande structure
de Big Pharma ici le Big Pharma et tu
parles justement des expérientations
qu'ils ont fait au Nigéria des
expérimentations comment tuappelles ça
écoute ce sont des expérimentations et
c'est et moi pour moi ça c'est des
crimes contre l'humanité vraiment je
suis pas un anti vaccination maladif ou
caricatural he tu as été vacciné pour le
covid je suis vacciné par le sérum de
vérité comprennent qui pourra c'est quoi
le sérum de vérité c'est ce qui permet
de parler aujourd'hui maintenant je t'en
dirai pas plus et tu me mettras pas dans
une situation dans laquelle je veux pas
rentrer tu as pas voulu me donner ton
carer de santé c'est un scandale ah
c'est vraiment mais c'est un scandale qu
dans une interview on te demande ton CER
de
santé donc
donc il y a il y a une défiance qui est
naturelle une méfiance mais quand les le
français du quotidien vient en Afrique
se comporte bien il y a aucun problème
mais quand il y a des dérives mais là
c'est le évidemment tout ce qui ressort
c'est ce que vos dirigeants font il y a
eu un épisode récent que que ma petite
sœur à qui je passe le le bonjour Safia
en jooy Life qui est une chroniqueuse
extraordinaire euh de dans dans mon
média à compter à raconter on était sur
l'île de Goré on était sur l'île de Goré
et il y a je sais pas il y a un un un
français pour le
coup au restaurant qui est en train de
de se comporter en parlant à des
Afro-Américains qui étaient
venus se recueillir parce que c'est un
lieu de pèlerinage gé pour ce qui est de
la traite pour ce qu' de l'esclavage la
déportation et il parlait cétait un
petit peu bruillant et le seul blanc du
coin commence à dire vous commencez à
faire en gros vous commencez à faire
chier à faire autant de bruit on peut
pas manger
tranquille touriste
le gars qui est touriste blanc il a le
droit de venir tout le monde peut venir
mais qui commence à dire ça à des
Afro-Américains mais le gars je sais pas
peut-être qu'il il voulait suicider ce
jour-l je sais pas on il y a différentes
façons de se suicider comme dirait ma
grande sœur natthalie il en est
différente et je pense qu'il avait
peut-être choisi celle-là mais les
nôtres ont ont réagi d'une manière
extrêmement digne il on fait un cours
d'histoire ils ont fait mais exactement
pour de vrai et ils ont rappelé la part
d'humanit qu' n'avait pas en lui et la
folie qu'il avait en lui et lui ont
rappelé que siil était tombé sur des
gens moins intelligents peut-être que
c'était son dernier jour qu'il allait
rencontrer c'est très intéressant ce que
tu dis est-ce que lui déjà était au
courant de ce qui s'était passé là-bas
il était au courant si il était au
courant il éta sa femme était une noire
sur place comme quoi c'est pas parce que
tu te maries à quelqu'un que ça veut pas
dire que tu ça te pose un problème le
métissage qu'on soit très clair et c'est
important j'en profite pour en parler
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de propagande
sur cette question parce que toi tu es
quand même tu es noir clair
quoibl je suis pas noir clair ma mère ma
mère est CLA très clair mon très clair
est clair mon père est très foncé tu te
mets de la crème qui fait blanchir ou
pas à ton avis franchement franchement
je même pas répondre à ta question
mais moi je crois comme disait Bob
Marley au black love je le crois
profondément je pense que c'est l'amour
noir qui manque à notre peuple pour s'en
sortir c'est l'unité parmi les nres qui
permettra de mieux être au reste de
l'humanité je le crois et est-ce que
justement c'est ma réponse je te réponds
et donc je je promeux en priorité
l'ondogamie communautaire je le dis de
manière très fluide mais mais c'est
attends attends attends attends mais
j'ai le droit mais le dire et prener
black love ne signifie pas que je
comment dirais-je que je suis insensible
au fait qu'il y a des gens de
différentes communautés qui peuvent
s'aimer et qui peuvent avancer et j'ai
un exemple un frère que je salue qui
s'appelle James un grand artiste connu
je va pas donner son nom de famille
sinon il va êre reconnu kry non
certainement pas ça c'est autre chose
enfin certainement pas je suis un âge où
c'est un frère si tu parles de carie
James c'est un frère j'ai pas de à une
époque je l'aimais pas trop parce que j'
j'avais du mal avec le le le une
revendication euh sur le terrain musical
que je ne sentais pas porter sur le
terrain moi je suis un activiste de
formation donc c'est mais je suis à un
âge où je j'aime j'aime j'aime les miens
et je les encourage dans tout ce qu'ils
font donc je l'aime je l'aime aussi
clairement et j'ai d'autres objectifs je
suis plus dans des querelles infantil
qui n'ont pas lieu d'être mais je parle
d' d'un frère qui est qui est le l'un
des fils de Manu Dibango James qui est
marié à une à une femme d'origine
ukrainienne qui est une femme
extraordinaire
et ce sont des gens qui qui sont très
touchés par ce qu'on fait et je vais
dire euh ah non ta femme est blanche je
te parle pas c'est ridicule je te pose
une question donc juste pour finir je si
tu me demandes ce que je prône je prône
le black Love en en ver et contre tout
et je prône la nécessité pour les nres
de nous aimer que ce soit charnellement
sentimentalement amicalement être
solidaire économiquement et cetera parce
qu'on est les plus grands consommateurs
à l'extérieur mais on ne consomme pas et
on ce que nous produisons et ça c'est un
vrai problème question concrète ton fils
tu as un fils ouais j'en ai deux ça va
tes deux fils h et j'ai deux filles
petit k tout beau sont plus beau que moi
bah c'est facile ferme
taeule on
coupera ce sera pas coupé ok y a pas de
souci ton fils il tombe amoureuse
amoureux d'une d'une belle blanche
rousse ou d'une belle blanche blonde il
vient de voir il dit papa je vais me
marier et toi tu lui dis bon est noir ou
elle est blanche qu'est-ce que tu dis je
vais te répondre très simplement je suis
quasi certain non non attends je suis
libre de mes
réponses mes enfants on étaient élevés
par des femme
noir très grande promotrice du Black
love de la culture
africaine la conscience noire
et ils ont été biberonnés depuis la
naissance à ce black love là ça ne veut
rien dire le cœur a ses raisons que la
raison par ça dépend c'est un proverbe
qui existe c'est vrai et j'ai mon
entourage proche des gens qui sont des
sœurs qui sont avec des blancs des
hommes noirs qui sont avec des blancs et
cetera donc il y a pas de souci dessus
mais on parle de ton fils hein ouais
mais mon mais mon fils ou mes fils
ou tes filles je suis prêt à mettre un
billet qui se mettront avec des noir un
gros billet parce que tu les empêcheras
moi j'empêche personne chacun doit être
comme il est et croire en ce qu'il croit
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce que
c'est ce qui te permet de d'avancer dans
la vie et ce que tu défends
il il y a tellement de femmes brillantes
en Afrique dans le monde noir de manière
général que si c'est saposexuel il va
trouver des baosexuel noir pas de
souci foncé ou clair j'ai pas de souci
mais il trouvera des afrodescendantes
moi c'est ce que je souhaite après s'il
vient avec une blonde aux yeux
bleus brune au yeux Mo marrons une brune
aux yeux marrons ça sera son choix ça
sera pas le choix de son père moi c'est
s te dit qu'il est gay
écoute si tu siil me dit qu'il est gay
tu veux que je fasse
quoi je vais brûlé parce qu'il me dira
qu'il est gay mais non il est g il est g
chacun est mett de son destin et c'est
les religions dans la religion il est
dit que dans les religions il est dit
que l'homosexualité ceci cela et cetera
c'est Dieu qui juge c'est pas moi qui
vais juger moi par contre je suis htro
et j'aime les femmes noires j'ai le
droit personne est parfait tu me diras
euh pour moi c'est la perfection mais
chacun a son définition de perfection
bon allez trêve de boutade et de
plaisanterie c'est quand même un sujet
sérieux oui très sérieux moi je suis
très sérieux c'est toi qui fait des
plisaneries dessus moi je suis très
sérieux revenons au business tu penses
que on va avoir besoin les uns des
autres pour affronter le réchauffement
climatique affronter les les pénuries de
ressources est-ce qu'il faut pas un
petit peu essayer de fluidifier les
choses arrêter d'énerver tout le monde
essayer de se tendre la main un peu
partout moi ta question me paraît
elle me paraît un peu
bisounourse et je je l'être humain a
besoin de l'autre par définition mais on
vit dans un dans tu sais pourquoi les
bisou nourse parce que je sais que tu as
un grand cœur ça c'est je le dis tu sais
le le monde a appris parfois à ceux qui
ont beaucoup d'amour à à devoir durcir
le ton parce que l'amour n'est pas le
langage le plus compris malheureusement
dans le monde aujourd'hui
mais t Doig de ta bouche on n'entend pas
on entend pas c'est peut-être volontaire
que je les mettre à ce momentl voilà
mais quand je te disais tout à l'heure
que l'unité parmi les nres permettra de
mieux nous unir avec le reste de l'umité
je crois fondamentalement déjà que pour
s'unir avec les autres il faut que tu tu
sois capable de tunir le plus dans ta
maison c'est important tu sois en paix
avec toi-même ça commence par exactement
l'alignement avec soi l'alignement avec
soi puis l'alignement avec ses
semblables et maintenant l'alignement
avec ses voisins puis l'alignement avec
les voisins lointains et cetera et
cetera et on avance et c'est pour ça que
je tu vois quand je quand tu me vois
être reçu alors on est très éclectique
dans nos partenariat dans nos alliances
là le dernier en dat qui a créé une
hystérie du système c'est être reçu au à
l'Assemblée nationale avec podemos
podemos on a des points communs sur la
critique du néolibéralisme économique je
peux te je suis désolé de te coupery
pourquoi tu tu mets pas tes comptes en
pas tes comptes tes sources de
financement en accès libre tu as vu tu
as déjà vu un mouvement de libération
qui met ces sources de de financement en
accellible la NC jamais quand ils ont
accédé au pouvoir oui avant jamais le
esbolla tuas déjà vu jamais Fred limo tu
as déjà vu jamais et urgence
panafricaniste tu verras pas non plus on
a un mouvement de libération on n'est
pas on n'est pas un mouvement de lafd on
n'est pas les féèes qui ell-même je suis
pas sûr qu'elles ont des sources de
financement très traçable donc c'est
gratuit hein j'ai dit je suis pas sûr
c'est pas gratuit c'est très payant pour
le
coup je pense qu' sont bien payés pour
ça
donc je reviens elles sont non il faut
tu peux il faut tu peux pas dire ça
c'est j'ai dit je suis sûr j'ai pas dit
que c'est une certitude j'ai dit je suis
sûr tu vois que moi j'emploie pas le on
j'emploie le jeu sur ça tu vois quand je
te dis onouis ouais très général alors
que on dit alors que c'est le microcosme
parisiano parisien les services secrets
français qui disent ça c'est pas le on
dit général en Afrique ils ont une autre
perception sur ça dans les territoires
d'autres mè aussi donc tu m'as coupé
j'étais en train de te parler avant des
mouvements de libération les alliances
ouais les alliances quand on va on est
reçu à podemos podemos on se retrouve
sur la critique du nolibéralisme
économique sur et et et c'est et nous on
est une structure qui est profondément
ancrée dans la lutte des classes
malheureusement parce qu'on a une un un
côté traditionnaliste pendant très
longtemps et c'est quelque chose qui
pour moi est un grand regr non je écoute
ce que je te dis c'est un grand regret
on a eu à faire en France depuis notre
plus jeune âge moi je suis venu avec un
logiciel l'antiracisme l'intégration et
cetera c'est pas mon sujet moi je suis
pas un fils d'immigré je suis un homme
noir d'accord un Africain afrodescendant
je ne le suis plus
et de toute façon j'ai objectivement pas
trop été traité comme tel non plus
pendant de nombreuses années à
différents égards mais on va pas pleurer
dans les chaumères il y a aucun souci
dessus est-ce que tu penses le fait que
tu es étais selon toit maltraité ça a
créé c'est le démon est-ce que le fait
que la gauche la droite s'invective que
les les les mouvements d'ultra droite
soit dur clé noir est-ce que ça crée des
démons est-ce que tu es devenu un démon
tu es devenu dur parce qu'on t'a
maltraité
euh et est-ce qu'il faut you give to
little infant can fuck everybody life
c'était
tu as vu vu mais bien sûr c'est la
colonisation et en plus je parle une
autre langue coloniale que l'anglais tu
as vu avec avec l'accent du premier ça
veut dire quoi en français la haine que
tu que tu donnes et que tu mets dans la
tête de petits enfants peut détruire
n'importe qui the give life c'est la
phrase de tpac et c'est une philosophie
de vie quand tu bouies des enfants quand
tu les pousses à l'exclusion quand ils
grandiront il seront dans une
démarche comment dirais-je
l'arithmétique de la rébellion oui c'est
ça l'injustice qu'un enfant ressent
quand il va grandir va la porter
autrement si tu vis la négrophobie de la
manière la plus caractérisée quand tu es
petit quand tu es enfant que tu ton père
t'emmène à l'école et qu'il y a des
bruits de singe quand vous sortez parce
que vous êtes noir vous avez 4 ans ou 5
ans ou quand vous rentrez dans un
supermarché par que vous êtes la seule
famille noire tu as une MRE qui est
extrêmement BCBG qui est bien habillé
qui est très belle je pas ce que ma mère
parce que c'est un obj c'est bon on est
tous subjectif sur nos maman on va dire
et que tu vous fait et vous vous faites
contrôler vous vous faites contrôler euh
et fouiller traiter comme des
sous-hommes parce que vous êtes noir
quand vous faites contrôler de manière
systématique par la police et que vous
faites l'objet de violence policière à
une époque où c'était pas encore à la
mode aujourd'hui c'est tras trendy
violence policière à l'époque ça l'était
pas euh il y avait pas George Floy et
cetera il y avait pas les caméras
raelle George Floyd pour ceux qui ne
savent pas benah George Floyd c'est un
un homme noir qui s'est fait assassiner
qui s'est fait arrêter qui n'arrive pas
respirer qui s'est fait assassiner en
étant étouffé par la police voilà lors
de son interpellation et c'est des cas
qui qui qui qui sont quotidiens donc
tous ces éléments là mais il y a aussi
aussi des gens qui a tempèent pas qui
sont chiants qui sont violents mais bien
sûr on n'est pas en train en fait qu'on
soit clair il y a pas d'ange ni de
démons il y a l'être humain
d'accord avec ses complexités il y a des
gens bons des gens mauvais partout
maintenant en ce qui concerne
l'oppression
euh la négrophobie c'est quelque chose
qui existe et moi quelque part je risque
de te surprendre je remercie ces gens-là
qui en propageant leur négrophobie
vis-à-vis de petits être comme nous
l'étions enfants m'ont permis de me
révéler à moi-même et de prendre
conscience de la nécessité de prendre
soin de moi-même et de mes semblable
est-ce que c'est une vengeance c'est pas
une vengeance si c'était une vengeance
j'allais dire mon frère mon frère en
humanité si c'était une vengeance je
pense qu'on se comporterait autrement et
on serait pas dans la nonvolence et le
pouvoir politique que l'on a aujourd'hui
en Afrique ou dans certains territoires
d'autres mè si c'était une vengeance ça
se passerait pas comme ça question
est-ce que c'est la justice qui nous
intéresse c'est pas la vengeance est-ce
que admettons qu'un jour
tacous d'indépendance de souveraineté de
libre arbitre d'autodétermination arrive
h est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre je dirais
nous l'Occident à la vengeance de
l'Afrique ça serait quoi la vengeance de
l'Afrique que l'Afrique reprenne son bah
ce serait souveré je donne l'exemple ce
serait bah voilà le Niger ou ailleurs un
autre territoire avec des matières
premières rappelez-vous comment vous
nous avez traité B maintenant prix de
l'uranium c'est 10 fois le prix pour
vous et c'est 10 % pour les Russes ou le
hzbollah ou les Iraniens ou ce que tu
veux si ce jour là arrive je pense que
ça serait intelligible ça serait
compréhensible ça ça peut se comprendre
ça pourrait se comprendre moi je ne tu
comprends qu'ils vont jamais lâcher les
autorités françaises ou ou ares
actuellement ils ont pas le choix ils
sont en train de le
faire même si c'est pas ce qu'ils
veulent ils sont en train de remigrer
vers l'Afrique anglophone d'ailleurs
très stratégiquement mais on leur
laissera pas le choix
s'attendre à la vengeance non moi ce que
je
souhaite je souhaite que vous soyez
décolonisé en France aussi parce que
vous êtes colonisée par une élite
néolibérale qui est une
élite qui est la la la excuse-moi mais
la prostituée politique de l'OTAN c'est
ce que disait verges non je suis pas sûr
c'est possible mais il disait si mes
souvenirs sont bons la France est devenu
la [__] des Américains ok bon tu vois
j'ai pas été là j'ai parlé de prostitué
politique de l'OTAN je même pas des
Américains par que en train de le boxon
qui est en train de se dérouler aux
États-Unis je dirait de l'OTAN en tant
que tel et on verra ce que l'OTAN va
devenir dans les temps à venir aussi
mais il faut que vous décolonisiez il
faut qu'il y a des gens comme des gens
comme Branco à la tête de ce pays en
France je pense vraiment des gens qui
pensent comme lui ou pas loin de lui qui
sont qui veulent la justice sociale
réelle parce que c'est le vrai
problème je je veux dire quand tu vas
dans les campagnes en France tu as
vraiment l'impression que tu es dans un
autre pays quand tu compares la France
et et le marigot parisien je par je
parle pour vous l'Afrique j'en parle
même pas je vais dire certains d'extrême
droite ils vont dire tu te balances dans
le 93 tu as l'impression d' dans un
autre pays mais bien sûr mais ils sont
parquet banlieu lieuannie bien sûr c'est
un are pays bien sûr avec une asphixie
sociale qui fait que
forcément quand il on est contonné d'une
certaine façon dans certains quartiers
tu tu vas pas c'est difficile de t'en
sortir autrement que en agissant de
certaine façon ça veut pas dire que tous
ceux qui sont issus de banlieu vont se
comporter mal c'est pas non plus le
propos mais l'incivisme l'injustice peut
créer parfois l'insvisme ne nous mentons
pas non plus et et et dans les campagnes
il y a aussi une autre forme d'insvisme
dû à un oubli à un mépris à une
centralisation de de tout des pouvoirs
et de tout ce qui s'ensuit qui fait
qu'une partie de la population est
oubliée et c'est ce système colonial qui
a été en réalité plus que jamais déployé
dans nos pays où tout est centralisé et
maintenant tout ce qui est dehors des
grandes villes et laissé pour compte et
ce sont ces zones justement laissées
pour compte qui sont les terrains les
terreau fertiles parfois des terroristes
parce que laisser pour compte parce que
exclus quand ils ont d'autres entités
qui viennent qui leur proposent un autre
schéma de société un autre schéma
civilisationnel et des moyens bien
certains jeunes dœuvrés finissent par
tomber dedans c'est aussi une réalité
l'injustice crée l'in civisme est-ce que
tu as un sujet que tu souhaites aborder
avec nous le Bénin si tu le permets
euh le Bénin je je suis un opposant
politique au président Patrice Talon qui
est le symbole à la fois de de de
l'ultralibéralisme le plus dérégulé
c'est l'une des plus grosses fortunes
fortune d'Afrique de l'Ouest et la plus
grosse fortune du Bénin il l'était déjà
avant de devenir président c'était le
faiseur de roi avant de devenir
Président il a été sa fortune a été
faite à base de quoi c'est le coton en
fait ça il y a une phrase qu'on dit
souvent au Bénin entreeneur il est il
est il est il a été fait milliardaire
par décret c'est-à-dire que c'est grâce
à ses relations à avec les avec chef
certains chefs d'État béninois ses
prédécesseurs il était dans les petits
papiers de certains certains ont signé
des décrets en leur disant bon
maintenant tu as ce marché là il s'est
jeté dessus c'est un très grand un très
bon opportuniste c'est important dans
les affaires très bon homme d'affair B
les deux sont souvent vont souvent de
père les Bones affaires les bonnes
affaires et les très bons hommes
d'affaires ce sont les gens qui ont sont
capables d'avoir le flair de savoir
flairer les opportunités et d'avancer
toi tu es opportuniste quand on dit
kemiseba c'est bombardé lui-même
poentete de diamant du panafricain 2.0
de diamant ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire capable de tout percer capable de
tout percer c'est qu ce que tu entends
par là ou dans le sens dans le sens où
c'est celui qui qui se met en première
ligne parce que c'est son business ah
ben business qui m'a amené à plusieurs
reprises en prison qui m'emmène à être
surveillé par les services secrets de
différents pays qui m'emmène à être
fiché au Département d'État américain
comme étant une des voies les plus
soi-disant hostile à l'hégémonie
occidentale business qui m'emène à avoir
une vie privée en pointillé business qui
me pousse moi ou ma femme ou mes proches
à être fiché à être surveiller avoir des
écoutes avoir des campagnes de calomnie
de diffamation business qui m'emmène à
avoir des menaces de mort quotidiennes
constantes c'est pas un business très
intelligent très sincèrement j'aurais
gagné beaucoup plus pourquoi les
américains ils t'ont fiché comme ils
m'ont fiché pour déjà j'étais fiché
avant parce que j'étais interdit depuis
la première fois que je suis allé en
Iran que j'étais reçu par les autorités
et cetera j'étais fiché j'étais fiché
aux États-Unis interdit d'accès aux
États-Unis alors que j'étais invité
régulièrement par les mouvements black
nationalistes et panafricanistes des
États-Unis et ensuite quand black
suprémaciste ou pas comment black
suprémaciste comme je t'ai dit la supr
ah non c'est dans une autre interview je
disais ça il y a eu un glissement
sémantique dans les années 60 on parlait
de pouvoir noir St Michael le
conceptualisit comme cela
l'autodétermination économique politique
culturelle des populations africaines et
afrodiasporiques et on est passé au 21e
siècle à une perception de de ce pouvoir
noir Black Power comme étant du
suprématisme noir ce qui est une
débilité prenez l'autodétermination des
tiens ça veut pas dire que tu prendes
une suprématie vis-à-vis des autres ça
signifie juste que tu veux que les tiens
puissent se prendre en charge avancer
sans être dans un cadre de victimisation
c'est black live matters comme ils
aimeraient qu'on le soit ils veulent
nous incarcérer dans la case de
l'antiracisme qu'on nexexiste qu'à
travers le regard de l'autre et moi j'ai
quelqu'un m'aime pas je m'en fous tu es
pas obligé de m'aimer tu m'aimes pas je
t'aime pas c'est tout par contre si tu
tentes de porter atteinte à mon
intégrité ça devient mon affaire et là
on rentre dans une autre dynamique et je
pense que c'est une valeur universelle
donc pas suprémaciste et et donc ensuite
là je reviens et quand il y a eu par la
suite leur approchement après l'Iran
avec la
Russie là les autorités américaines
oui c'est une voie de désinformation
anti-occidentale proche de prigzine et
cetera proche de l'Iran et tout ce qui
sont est-ce que tu as lu le le c'est je
me rappelle plus je demande àêtre fa
checké le rapport de lufri non le le le
fait que en fait B tu as mal fait ton
boulot et et et que c'est simplement les
politiques de la France qui ont qui ont
mis un petit peu
d'animosité ça m'a fait rire mais
reformule-moi ça en gros ils
reconnaissent 1000 ans après que les
premiers responsables de ce qui se passe
en Afrique c'est la bêtise des
gouvernants français qui se sont
comportés de manière coloniale vis-à-vis
de de nos populations et c'est c'est pas
la Russie c'est et c'est pas le une une
manipulation visant à faire monter les
sentiments antifrançais qui fait qu'il y
a une hostilité visàvis de la politique
française en Afrique c'est la la
mauvaise gouvernance française la
mauvaise politique étrangère française
vis-à-vis des populations africaines ils
le reconnaissent et ça c'est une réalité
et c'est pas antinomique avec le fait
que nous menions ce travail d'éveil des
consciences pour sensibiliser les
populations pour que cell-ci comprenne
la nécessité de se tenir à l'écart
justement de ce système néocolonial
voilà revenons revenons au sujet que tu
souhaitais aborder avec nous le Bénin
bén c'est un beau pays tu as des coins
tu as des coins n à nous recommander si
on va là-bas prochaine fois qu'on ira je
t'emmènerai dans plein de coins non mais
moi on y va tout seul LEC non par contre
je veux bien que tu m'invites au mariage
de ton fils quand il va se marier avec
une belle rousse toi tu as des
prévisions sombres pourquoi non mais on
verra mais je sais que ça sera une belle
noire su quasiment convaincu bon dans
les deux cas si c'est une belle rousse
oublie pas ton ticket il il y a pas de
problème il y a pas de souci bon
revenons au Bénin et trêve de plaisan
les femmes noires sont tellement belles
que c'est difficile de choisir autre ch
d'autres ma grand-mère disait ça ta
grand-mère qui a grandi en Afrique
connaî pas grandi vécu en elle elle elle
a passé un peu de temps bon revenons
revenons à notre sujet le Bénin donc le
Bénin je suis un opposant politique
justement Patrice Talon qui est l'outil
du néolibéralisme économique le plus
dérégulé qui existe qui a euh accentué
comme jamais auparavant depuis la
période des indépendances les inégalités
sociales au sein de nos populations qui
sur le manifeste comment alors par une
popérisation endémique de population par
des des des des plaintes à tel point que
lui-même lors de son second mandat a été
obligé de reconnaître publiquement que
il avait failli sur le terrain de la
justice sociale et qu'il allait faire un
effort parce qu'il il il est très alerte
de ce qui se dit même si il travaille
pas
forcément comment dirais-je il n'est pas
suffisamment efficient pour corriger le
tir la preuve mais c'est c'est aussi une
belle preuve d' conduite introspective
de reconnaître et de ver reconnaître
reconnaître sans corriger c'est une
introspection à michemin ça dommage mais
non je dois aussi reconnaître parce que
j'aime être objectif que il a suivi ce
qui avait été commencé par d'autres sur
le terrain infrastructurel le Bénin a
connu un un surtout les grandes villes
surtout Cotonou a connu une avancée
réelle sur la construction des routes
mais on dit toujours que si tu
développes les infrastructures mais que
tu détruis les humains qui utilise ses
infrastructures et bien les
infrastructures seront des cimetières et
c'est exactement ce dont il s'agit sur
notre Terre mère qui est le Bénin où on
a aujourd'hui une popérisation endémique
une injustice sociale galopante et on a
une hyperclasse qui s'enrichit comme
jamais auparavant et c'est de toute
façon ce que crée le néolibéralisme dans
nos pays c'est pas une une philosophie
économique qui est en adéquation avec
nos réalités qu'on le veuille ou pas
et je fais partie de ceux qui veulent
être une al alternative à Patrice Talon
je ne le cache pas tu es en train de
m'annoncer ta j'annonce rien j'annonce
rien je te dis juste que je souhaite
être une alternative à Patrice Talon
Patrice Talon le sait ils le font passer
régulièrement dans leurs médias en
disant que il me il me soupçonne de
vouloir faire un coup d'état alors c'est
peut-être leur mauvaise conscience qui
les gratent parce que on est dans un
pays au Bénin où 90 % du corps électoral
est exclu les opposants ne peuvent pas
concourir aux élections les seuls qui
peuvent concourir c'est un peu comme
dans un combat truqué ce sont ceux qui
sont choisis par le Président si le
président décide que toi il accepte que
tu puisses concourir tu concours mais
ces challengerss les plus dangereux il
les amis en exil d'accord où il créent
des campagnes de diabolisation pour leur
en tout cas leur empêcher de rentrer sur
le territoire et dans des cas comme ça
quand tu n'as pas la possibilité de
pouvoir avoir des élections ouvertes
quelles sont les options pour accéder au
pouvoir moi je ne le prendne pas mais
comme au au Mali comme au Burkina Faso
comme au Niger si tu bloque tout talon
arrête tout tout le monde à tir la Rigo
là il y a quelques jours il un de mes
proches le général Louis philippeignnon
a été arrêté pour harcèlement par voie
électronique juste parce qu'il critique
la malgouvernance du régime moi j'ai été
arrêté critique comment avec de manière
extrêmement polie et sourcée sur les
textes de droit que lui c'est vraiment
la personne qui ne fallait pas arrêter
c'était le chef de la gendarme nationale
la gendarmerie nationale auparavant qui
est maintenant dans l'opposition qui
travaille avec nous qui est dans une
démarche de de de critiquer sur le
terrain juridique les manquements du
régime Patrice Talon qui est dans une
démarche de de de dire ce qui ne va pas
il a été arrêté il y a un autre qui sont
partis kidnapper au Togo qui s'appelle
steveamousu d'accord qu'on soupçonne
d'être un internaute cyberactiviste qui
critiquait de manière très polie le
régime Patrice Talon est-ce qu'il est
financé par des puissances étrangères
aussi aussi mdr je sais pas à quoi le
aussi fait allusion mais mais il a été
kidnappé par un lui a reproché d'être
financé désolé pour la la question
est-ce qu'on lui a noniss non pas ma
connaissance ils sont allés kidnapper
comme des lâche à quatre quatre ou C non
quatre ils sont partis kidnapper et puis
ils l'ont ramené au Bénin on on vide la
République de gondoana d'un humoriste
qui est pas très drôle d'ailleurs
comment il s'appelle
euh je crois que c'est maman ou je sais
pas comment il s'appelle qui a il a créé
un sketch sur la République dictatoriale
euh une république dictatoriale
africaine où t tous les droits sont
Bafou et cetera mais c'est exactement ce
qui se passe dans notre pays il y a pas
de loi et on a un autocrate qui n'a
jamais été aussi puissant qui s des lois
au Bénin non sont pas respectés il y a
une cour spéciale dès que tu déranges le
Président on t'envoie cette cour de
reprépression contre les crimes
économiques et contre le terrorisme
alors aujourd'hui critiquer sur Facebook
c'est du terrorisme on en arrive là et
ce que je regrette dans nos pays c'est
qu'on n pas réussi à appréhender le le
désaccord par le dialogue et qu'on
systématiquement on agisse dans ce cadre
de désaccord par comment dirais-je
l'exil ou la prison je trouve ça dommage
luouis philippeignon récemment et on
fera tout pour le libérer moi j'ai été
arrêté mais patate chaude toujours il
m'a il m'a libéré au bout de quelques
heures
euh il y a le représentant de de
l'antenne de mon organisation agence
panafricaniste au Bénin le frère Chadrac
un élément extrêmement brillant que je
salue aussi qui a été arrêté et puis
libéré
je je veux dire il passe son temps
arrêter il y a ma sœur reat madouou qui
a arrêté depuis qui qui vit dans des
conditions inadmissible qui est une
ancienne ministre et qui était une de
ces challengeuses et qui a qui persécute
il y a le constitutionnaliste Joel ao
qui a arrêté je veux dire on est on est
dans un pays qui asphixie son peuple il
y a aujourd'hui les gens disent il y
aura plus de place dans les prisons
parce que talon il arrête n'importe qui
tous ceux qui osent dire que ça ne va
pas mais son spectacle va s arrêter et
nous travaillons et c'est peut-être pour
ça qu'il fait tout pour que crimin pour
criminaliser ma démarche et que son
objectif c'est de me mettre en prison
s'il le peut moi j'en ai fait le
sarmment et nous réussirons talon et son
Poulin qu' choisira ne seront pas au
pouvoir aux prochaines élections ils ne
gagneront pas tant que les élections ne
seront pas ouvertes à forceori ils ne
gagnera pas est-ce que tu as trois
livres à conseiller à ma communauté oui
j'ai trois livres à te conseill
euh le premier qui tuas pas le droit de
citer les
tiens je fais bien de le préciser la
crise du monde moderne de René
Genon très bon livre pourquoi tu l'as
aimé parce que il il a dit il a
verbalisé dans le monde occidental ce
que les Africains savent depuis de
nombreuses années en ce qui concerne la
dérive du
modernisme un modernisme dont
certains occidentaux pas tous mais se
targuent se ventent alors que c'est
quelque chose de profondément décorrélé
déconnecté de sur certains aspects en
tout cas de toute dynamique liée à la
spiritualité selon moi sur les autres
c'est la sortie de la
pauvreté la médecine entre autres et
cetera là on va rebondir sur mon mon
ouvrage philosophieque de la
panafricanité fondamentale qui qui
s'inscrit dans ce casadre justement de
l'école pérénialiste traditionnaliste et
donc par conséquent qui aborde aussi
dans un dans une perspective africaine
ces termes là mais comme tu m'as dit de
pas faire des promotions de mon lit
philosophie de la Panafrican
fondamentale je vais pas le faire et
qu'on peut trouver dans bon nombre
d'endroit de grande surface à différents
endroit
PIM que Belmar mais plus sérieusement
deè livre après la crise du monde
moderne civilisation barbarie de
charerantadiop j'encourage tout le monde
à le lire parce que c'est un livre
extraordinaire très important
euh discours sur le colonialisme des m
céser j'aimerais que tu donnes un
conseil pour les jeunes générations une
bouteille à la
mer quelque chose
d'impérissable n'attendez pas la
validation
d'autrui pour croire en vous pour
exister et pour essayer de faire avancer
l'humanité euh
ce que les élites ne font pas pour vous
débrouillez-vous pour le faire par
vous-même et
enfin aimer quand il est possible
d'aimer autrui aimer quand vous avez
possibilité d'aimer quand on vous donne
de du respect donner du respect et si on
vous manque de respect faites comprendre
par des moyens raisonnés à ceux qui vous
manquent de respect qu'il serait
préférable pour eux qu'ils arrêent ce
manque de respect là kemiba merci c'est
moi qui vous remercie je suis très
touché par cette invitation cette
émission merci
[Musique]